MARCO PAGLIA: Hi, everybody.
And welcome to this workshop.
My name is Marco, and I'm
an Android designer.
Or even better, my name is
Marco, and I'm proud to be an
Android designer.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: We have
a good crowd.
I mean, let's face it,
Android design is
just becoming amazing.
When I look at the applications
that we have in
our market, they are
just becoming
astounding day by day.
I'm so happy about where
we're going.
I really feel that the
introduction of the Android
style guide was a massive
step forward
in the right direction.
Google cares about
design as well.
I mean, today you could have
had all sessions just about
design, if you wanted to.
Raise your hands.
How many people have
been to design talk
during this Google I/O?
That's what I'm talking about.
Design and Android are just a
fantastic synergy together.
And with the right development,
we can build the
most amazing platform ever.
I'm not alone running
this workshop.
I have a lot of design team
here with me to help out.
And let them introduce
for themselves.
RICHARD FULCHER: Hi.
I'm Rich Fulcher.
You may remember me from
45 minutes ago.
I'm an interaction designer on
the Android Design team.
JEREMY LYON: Hi.
I'm Jeremy Lyon.
I'm also an interaction
designer on the
Android Design team.
RACHEL GARB: Hi.
I'm Rachel Garb, also an
interaction designer on the
Android team.
JENS NAGLE: I'm Jens Nagle,
Interaction Designer, Android
Design team.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Rich.
PETER INGHAM: Hello.
I'm Peter Ingham, a visual
designer on the
Android Design team.
AUDIENCE: Woo.
[LAUGHTER]
MARCO PAGLIA: Woo.
GUENTHER BEYER: My name's
Guenther Beyer.
I'm a designer at GigBeat.
MICHAEL NOVAK: I'm Mike Novak,
the developer of GigBeat.
ERIC BURKE: My name
is Eric Burke.
I'm with Square.
And I'm not a designer.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: So why
are we here today?
Why are we running
this workshop?
As many of you, I just like
reading blogs and finding out
things about Android and all
the discussions that people
are having about the patterns
and the Android style guide
and everything.
And there's a particular topic
that I was really caught by
and really dragged my attention
into, which is,
today, we see a lot of new
applications coming up.
We have tons of applications
coming up every day.
We have very popular
applications that are coming
to Android.
And people discuss about whether
they are using the
right patterns, whether they
should use the right pattern,
if they are not using
the right pattern,
and things like that.
There's a particular question
that comes up once in a while.
And it really made me think
about it, which is, if every
application is using the style
guide, it doesn't mean we're
going to have all applications
look the same.
Well, the answer is,
obviously, not.
Quite the opposite, actually.
I really believe that Android
is the ecosystem out there
that offers the maximum
flexibility to really make
your brand to shine and be
different from all the other
applications in the market.
So there's something very
important that we need to
understand.
Being consistent and adapting
the right pattern to your
application, it doesn't mean
that your application has to
be looking the same
like others.
You have many, many
ways to make your
application to look special.
I mean, who would like to have
an ecosystem just to be very
boring and looking the same?
Think about human beings.
We're all different.
If you look around, there's no
one that looks like you.
We also dress up differently to
distinguish from one another.
[LAUGHTER]
When we're outside Google I/O.
And I think this is the way
that I'd like our ecosystems to
be, to have very different
application.
At the same time, human beings
have very consistent patterns,
even if you don't speak the
language of someone else.
I'm sure people here come
from all over the world.
I come from Italy.
And we may not know
the same language.
But if I smile, or if I get
angry, or if I raise up my
voice, people do understand
what I mean.
And so we want our application
to have that standard,
consistent way of behaving to be
consistent across Android.
So how do we do it?
Well, the style guide is a great
example of how you need
to make certain things
very consistent.
Because when they're not
consistent, we just break the
user maintained model.
Learning an ecosystem, learning
an operating system
is difficult.
You start playing with it, you
start swiping around, you
start learning some gestures.
And when not all the
applications use them
consistently, then you
just don't know how
to operate any more.
So you want to know where
my settings are.
You want to know that, if I see
different views next to
each other, I can swipe
through it.
You want to know where the
action bar is with all the
main actions.
But at the same time, you
want to make it special.
And there are ways to do it.
You can play with graphics.
You can play with gradients.
It's not true that all
applications on
Android has to be flat.
Like we like the style, so we
adopt it that way in the core
applications.
But, by any means, if your brand
is soft and wants to
have gradients and little
treatment in the action bars
and across the UI,
that's welcome.
We want an ecosystem to
be very different.
The way your little elements
animate from one another, if I
tap on a list view, how does it
zoom into a full view, this
is all up to you.
And I think the more,
the merrier.
The more diversity we can find
in our ecosystem, the more
people are going to find little
special things to make
their application even
more interesting.
And I love to see it
when it happens.
So this is why we're here.
We want to deliver this
simple message.
Designing for Android allows you
to have applications that
feels unique, that
feels beautiful.
And at the same time,
they're very
consistent and easy to use.
So to do that, this time we
organize the workshop.
In fact, this is not
really a talk.
I don't even have slides.
But we have people coming
up on stage later.
We have five developers that are
going to be showing their
applications and going to be
talking to us about the
challenges that they face.
And then we're going to have
open discussions around what
we suggest, what
they could do.
No dogma, though, just thinking
about possibilities
and really have an interesting
and nice friendly talk about
the challenges that the
patterns offer.
Before we get to that, though,
I'm really, really excited to
have two guest speakers
here on stage with us.
They introduced themselves
before.
They are representative of two
of my favorite applications.
We have Square and
we have GigBeat.
So we're going to hear
their story.
Most recently, they have created
their applications
following, most recently,
Android style guide pattern.
So we're going to hear what they
did and why they did it.
And I think the result
is excellent.
They really are applications
that feel so different from
one another, although they're
very consistent in
the way you use them.
And I love that.
So without further ado, let me
introduce our first guest
speaker, Eric Burke.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC BURKE: OK.
So like I said, I am
not a designer.
I am a software engineer.
I've been with Square for about
2 and 1/2 years now.
And what a lot of you might
not know is, when I joined
Square, there were only two
of us creating the Android
application.
It was Bob Lee and myself.
And we made the first version of
the Square app on Android.
And we're very proud of the fact
that, on the day that our
first iPhone app was released
publicly, we also released our
Android app--
same day.
That was two years ago.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC BURKE: So I think more
companies should do the same.
We just released an upgrade
to Pay With Square a
couple of weeks ago.
Again, same day,
both platforms.
Earlier this week, we released
an upgrade to our Square Card
Reader product.
We just re-skinned it
to use the Ice Cream
Sandwich and Holo look.
So we're very proud of the
work we're doing here.
So without further ado, let's
take a little history lesson
and look at where Pay With
Square originated.
This was our Card Case
application.
This is what our app used
to look like on Android.
This was well before Android
design guidelines were out.
This is what we call a
skeuomorphic design.
So skeuomorphic means you're
trying to make an application
look like a real world object.
Now in this case, obviously,
it looks like this gorgeous
leather wallet.
And it has cards in there.
And it looks like
something real.
It's pretty.
People really loved the look.
But from a design perspective,
it has a lot
of interaction problems.
So first of all, let's look
at technically on Android.
This is really hard
to pull off.
I worked a lot of hours trying
to get this thing to look
right on Android.
And I think, technically,
it just slowed us down.
Also, as more and more screen
sizes come out, stretching a
bitmap like this ends up
producing fuzzy graphics, and
that's not cool.
From a usability perspective,
you can only hold, really,
four cards.
The top card, that's your
merchant card, that actually
has a hologram in the corner.
And I think Apple copied us.
When they move their phone, they
have a little hologram on
their little, shiny,
silver thing.
We did that in our app also.
But for the merchants, you
can only hold four cards.
So that's a problem
scalability-wise.
Also, to actually make a payment
with this product, you
had to first drag a card
out of the pocket and
then press a button.
So it's multiple taps
just to perform
the most basic operation.
To see nearby merchants,
you had to tap the
Explore Places button.
Again, it's multiple taps to
get to anywhere in the app.
Well, the good thing
is, it's pretty.
The problems are, it requires
multiple taps to do anything.
It's technically very
challenging.
It slows us down.
And as phones get bigger,
it looks more fuzzy.
So we threw it all away.
We completely redid it.
And this is what Pay With
Square looks like today.
These are actually some of
the secondary screens.
So on the left, you see
the Twitter view.
And as you can see, it
has an action bar.
It has a view pager.
You can do the whole horizontal
swipe gesture.
On the right, I'll get
more into the detail
on that in a minute.
It's definitely an
Android app now.
No one is going to look at
this and say that's a
skeuomorphic design or
that's an iPhone app.
It looks totally like Android.
What I'm not showing here is,
when we first started
prototyping this, we went
with a dark theme.
So it was a lot of
black on black.
And it looked kind of dreary.
It looked, maybe, the app feel
like you're in a nightclub.
So we ended up going
with a light theme.
And I think it's totally
appropriate for a dark theme
in a music player app,
which you're
going to see in a minute.
But for a payments application,
the light theme
worked better.
We're also using dark
action bars.
In the original iteration of
this, the action bar color
would change, depending
on what merchant you
were looking at.
Each merchant had a theme and
a graphic, so it became more
of a showcase for
the merchants.
But I think we came to the
conclusion that it looked a
little gaudy to be changing
the color constantly.
And again, that was really nasty
to implement, because
you can't change the theme of
an activity after you've
launched it, without
some heroic hacks.
So we went back to a more
streamlined, basic approach
with the light theme and
the dark action bar.
So I really like where
it landed.
Let's walk through the product
and see what it actually does.
So obviously, we all
want bacon, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC BURKE: Yeah.
A round of applause for bacon.
So this is all about
making payments.
So when you pull out the app
and launch it, this is your
home screen.
This is the Directory view.
At the top, you see,
what we call, the
Curated Merchants view.
These are some of our
featured merchants.
It's a gallery that slides
from left to right.
It's full-bleed image.
It has the little overlay
in the middle.
But it just is a gorgeous
representation of the best
merchants in the system.
Below that, we have
a list view that
shows nearby merchants.
And you can fit a lot more
information into this design.
You can fit in information
about specials.
You can fit in functionality
to open a tab.
You can fit in the distance.
So contrast this with the
original Card Case design
where it was this gorgeous piece
of leather with cards.
But none of that was
ever actionable.
You had to go through multiple
taps to actually do anything.
So a key part of this design is
to reduce friction and make
the payment experience
effortless.
So by reducing the number of
taps, fitting more information
into the main screen, the whole
user interface becomes a
lot more usable.
So when you want your
bacon, you tap the
button to open a tab.
And then you walk up to
the Bacon Bacon truck.
You place your order.
And then you say,
put it on Eric.
And they will see my photo
on their register,
along with my name.
And they can tap a button
to charge me.
And then I can put my phone
away, and I'm done.
And I have my delicious bacon.
And I've made a payment.
So internally at Square, we talk
a lot about the notion of
humanizing payments.
We'd rather the payment
experience be about an
exchange between two people,
rather than an exchange
between you and the
technology.
So we really want to reduce the
number of taps and make
the app as effortless
as possible.
So we can take this
one step farther.
We can actually enable a feature
called Auto Tab.
So this app is deceptively--
it looks like a really
simple app.
There are only a few screens in
the app, but it's actually,
technically, really difficult
to code something like this.
So with Auto Tabs, you can
put your phone away.
And then, as you're walking
around, when you get within a
certain radius of your favorite
merchant, it'll
automatically open a tab.
So if I like coffee, I can set
up an auto tab for Sightglass
Coffee, which is just a few
blocks away from here.
I highly recommend it.
Also San Francisco Baking
Company is another great
merchant that's a
few blocks away.
So I think these small
businesses would be thrilled
if 700 or 800 people installed
the app and just did a cash
mob and walked in and ordered
these amazing cookies or this
amazing coffee.
So that's my product plug.
But with Auto Tabs,
it's the ultimate.
You never have to touch
your phone.
So the technology
just disappears.
So we put a lot of emphasis on
pixel pushing, and making
everything the right
colors, and getting
the alignment perfect.
But in reality, our goal is to
make the interface vanish
completely.
And that's the goal of Pay With
Square, is just to make
it go away.
So we did bring cards
back in the latest
iteration of the app.
So the first screen shot,
I showed you a
skeuomorphic design.
We got rid of the cards.
And what we found was that the
user interface was a little
bit boring.
And it was just a bunch of
images with list views.
So we brought back, in
the latest iteration,
the notion of cards.
And I really love the
way these look.
They're not shaped like
a credit card.
They're actually shaped like a
square with rounded corners.
We do that a lot in our web
site and our applications,
because our company's called
Square and that's what our
logo looks like.
And I made a little square
robot here for my shirt.
So cards are great because it's
something tangible that
humans can relate to.
It's something that
you can touch.
You can share cards.
You'll see the same card on the
web site, in your Android
phone, on the iPhone.
You can email cards.
This is a showcase for the
merchants, so the merchant's
photos show up on here.
The merchants can put
menus on here.
Eventually, we're going to
have more information,
directions to the merchant.
You can have punch cards,
specials, discounts,
first-visit rewards.
All that stuff shows
up on the card.
So a card is a concrete,
tangible thing in your UI that
users can explore and
play around with.
And it's a delightful way to
do the user interface.
But even with the cards,
it's not designed to be
skeuomorphic.
It's not designed to stray
too far from an
Android-inspired feel.
So I really like what
we did here.
For images, getting a
little geeky here.
The server provides
the images to us.
Since there's so many different
screen sizes, we
actually have a library.
It's internal.
I can't really share it
with you right now.
But we actually ask our server,
give me the image at
this exact pixel width
and height.
And then we also ask the server
to do layering and
compositing.
So the server can add the little
square and the borders
and rounded corners
and all that.
And then, that way, it returns
the exact right image for the
Android device.
In the list view there, you
see, again, we're using
squares with rounded corners.
I know the Android look is more
towards full-bleed images.
And we did try that in some
early iterations.
We just never could get it to
look quite right for our
taste, so we went with
the rounded corners.
I think that's OK.
No one's really screamed at us
for not doing full-bleed
images in lists.
I think you have some
latitude there.
Launcher shortcuts, we do this
in our Android client.
We don't do this, obviously,
in our iPhone
client, because you can't.
This is really cool, though.
You can just tap
the icon in the
upper-right interaction bar.
And you can add a shortcut to
your favorite merchant.
It puts it on your desktop.
So there I have a Bacon
Bacon link.
So now, whenever I'm near the
truck, I can just tap that
icon and open a tab at the
Bacon Bacon truck.
We take advantage of Android
Notifications pretty heavily.
So whenever you have a tab open,
a notification is open.
So you can take a phone call
while you're waiting in line,
or browse the web, whatever.
You can always come
back to your tab.
And something I'm not showing
here is, once your tab is
closed, you can leave a tip.
So you can order your coffee,
drink it, walk away.
And then, 10 minutes later, you
can pull out your phone
and say, oh, that was really
great coffee, I
want to leave a tip.
And you can do it right
there from your phone.
Merchants love to get tips.
So when I saw the keynote the
first day, the very first
thing I saw, when I saw the
notification enhancements, is
we should put tipping
in there.
So I'm really excited about
Jelly Bean and being able to
take advantage of that even
further than what we do now.
So for sharing, you
can share cards.
We use Android's normal
sharing mechanism.
We don't try to embed a Twitter
log-in into our app
and a Facebook log-in and
all those stupid things
that other apps do.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC BURKE: Yeah.
This actually ends up being more
powerful, because you can
share with things you
never even imagined.
Because I have the Bar
Code Scanner app
installed on my phone--
I was actually giving
a demo of the app to
my boss, Jack Dorsey.
And he looked at it.
And when I shared something,
he said, what is that?
Why does it say bar code?
I was like, I have no idea.
I've never seen that.
Let's try it out.
So I tapped the button, and it
generates this bar code.
And then he pulls out his
phone, and he scans it.
And sure enough, I just shared
a card with a bar code.
And we never wrote a single
line of code to do that.
So that was pretty amazing.
And then, just to wrap it up,
if you go to your account
settings, this looks more like
a stock Holo look and feel.
This is a visual cue that
you're kind of in the
underbelly of the app messing
with your account settings.
So our philosophy at Square
is we want our app to look
exactly the same on every
single Android phone.
So we back-ported as
much as possible.
We actually hired Jake
Wharton, who wrote
ActionBarSherlock.
And it's a great library.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC BURKE: Yes.
Thank you, Jake.
And we're actually committed
to keeping that open source
and continuing to innovate
on that.
And we've got some
more open source
libraries coming up soon.
We use a compatibility library,
fragments, loaders,
all that stuff.
So no matter what Android phone
you're on, it's going to
look exactly the same and
provide a consistent user
experience.
So that is Pay With Square.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: Let's have a
little chat here about what we
saw, what we like.
Probably everything.
I think the application we just
saw is just so awesome.
And the message that
I take out of it is
rounded squares are fine.
There's nothing bad
about them.
It's really about your
applications.
It's how you feel about it.
And you saw this application
is pretty special.
It has cards.
It has a lot of different
metaphors that you haven't
seen much before Jelly Bean on
Android, but still feels very,
very consistent with
our ecosystem.
There's one thing that I
particularly loved about it,
which is the use of
the big pictures.
This is something that I can
never enforce enough.
Pictures can never be too big.
It's a sort of mantra of mine.
And if you have them,
just use them.
And thinking about an
application that is so human,
so human that you don't even
have to look at it when you
pay, just providing the simple
thing, the simple, attractive,
big picture of the bar, is just
something that really,
really makes your application
shine.
Is there any question for
Eric from the audience?
We have microphones there.
So when you feel like you want
to participate and say
something, feel free
to run up.
And we'll try to
get questions.
We want this to be more
of open discussions.
We're not going to have
Q&A at the end.
ERIC BURKE: My presentation
was perfect.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: All right.
ERIC BURKE: I think it'd be
great to have some questions.
So while you're walking up here,
I'll share an anecdote.
When we first went away from the
wallet metaphor and went
to the new design, we actually
had a whole bunch of
complaints on Google Play.
People were furious at us for
taking away the wallet.
They thought we made it look
uglier and more boring.
So anyway, I think those
people are all wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC BURKE: I think it does go
to show that you can't always
listen to everybody
who complains.
No matter what you do, when
you change your design,
someone's going to complain.
So anyway, yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Nice design.
Did you take in account, by
doing the cards, any form of
sharing of payments
into account?
ERIC BURKE: Sharing--
so right now, when you
share, you just share
a link to the merchant.
So we're not doing sharing, like
peer-to-peer payments or
anything like that.
Right now, it's strictly
sharing the card.
Like I went to Sightglass.
I love their coffee, so I'm
going to Tweet about it.
So there's an icon
to share it.
Yeah, in the lower-right, I
can tap that and then it
brings up the Share Action
Provider menu.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
MARCO PAGLIA: Yeah.
And particularly this screen,
I think, is very interesting
how the Square guys, they
have embedded all
actions in this card.
It just feels so natural to have
actions embedded directly
in the view, rather than in
the action bar right here.
Having an action bar, obviously,
doesn't mean that
all the actions have
to be there.
It really depends on the view.
ERIC BURKE: We struggled a
lot with that, actually.
Early iterations put more
in the action bar.
But then it would go
into overflow.
And we just found that people
didn't discover things, if
they're not right there,
visible on the screen.
So that's been something we've
iterated on a lot.
Yeah.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Hey, how's it going?
So I'm curious if you ended up
factoring in some customer
usability studies, or any work
like that, into your UI design
as you were evolving it.
ERIC BURKE: No.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC BURKE: I wish we would
do more of that.
One thing we do, we do have
a customer insights group.
And their whole job is to
meet with merchants.
And they do a lot of
observations of the payment
experience.
And they talk to people.
But we're not really doing
formal usability studies yet.
And I'm hoping I can help
make that happen.
I think it's something
we should do more of.
But right now, no.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Cool.
Thanks.
ERIC BURKE: Yep.
MARCO PAGLIA: We'll take
two more questions,
and then we go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a little
bit technical question.
I want to ask when do you
fetch for images?
Are there any kind of
pre-fetching on the
backgrounds maybe?
ERIC BURKE: So the question is,
when do we fetch images?
So that's a tough engineering
problem that we're putting a
lot of emphasis on for the next
release, probably, is to
do a lot more caching.
We don't do a tremendous amount
of pre-fetching, but we
do cache images on
the file system.
So hopefully, when you come
back, you see the same images.
And we're investing a lot of
resources to make that even
better in future versions.
That's actually been
a very tough
problem to solve, though.
AUDIENCE: View one looked
very similar on
the iPhone and Android.
And then you switched to having
different looks and
feels on both platforms.
Was that a tough brand
decision to make?
ERIC BURKE: Yeah.
The philosophy at Square in the
early days was that both
apps had to look identical.
And I was never thrilled
with that.
But we really have two primary
mobile applications.
We have the payer application
and the seller application.
So in the seller application,
I am accepting a
payment from you.
But at some point, I hand
my phone over to you.
And then you sign your signature
on the screen.
So in the seller app, it's
actually more important to
have consistency across
platforms.
Because if I'm buying something
and I walk up to you
and I'm signing my name and
giving you my credit card, I
want that application
to be trustworthy.
So I need it to look
consistent.
From the payer experience,
though, this is my phone and I
never give it to anybody else.
And I'm in Android
all day long.
So in the payer experience, we
have flexibility to be more
creative on the different
platforms and we can diverge a
little bit.
It was funny.
One of the engineers made the
comment when we were first
going through this, he was
like, you know, what's
actually happening is our iPhone
client is becoming more
like an Android application.
Because they went with a lot of
the full-bleed images also,
and it made the iPhone client
look more like Android.
But yeah, because of the
audience, we feel like we can
make each app look a little
bit more different on the
different platforms.
Yep.
MARCO PAGLIA: OK.
And on this great
question, let's
give a round of applause.
ERIC BURKE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: All right.
Let me introduce you to the
next guest speakers.
They are the creators of
GigBeat, Michael Novak and
Guenther Beyer.
[APPLAUSE]
GUENTHER BEYER: Hello.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Do you
have the slides?
MARCO PAGLIA: Sorry.
MICHAEL NOVAK: We rock
Google Docs.
So as Marco said, we're GigBeat,
which is a concert
application for Android.
It helps you find when your
favorite artists are going to
be in your city.
You'll actually need to be--
GUENTHER BEYER: Go ahead?
MICHAEL NOVAK: No,
it's all you.
Yes.
So it lets you find out.
So it's great to go to shows,
but I found myself missing
shows all the time, just not
finding out about it until
somebody says, you missed an
amazing show last night.
I don't know why you
weren't there.
It's like, thanks,
for inviting me.
So I decided to solve that
problem by creating the
application that would let me
follow my artists and know
when they're going to actually
be in my city well before even
tickets usually sometimes
go on sale.
And it lets us really get
excited about shows.
So yeah, that's GigBeat.
GUENTHER BEYER: We want to show
a couple of patterns that
we introduced to GigBeat,
because it has about six
months of evolution behind it.
And I think the first one
might be branding.
Branding is always tough,
because on one side, you have
to create something
that stands out.
On the other hand, you have to
create something that feels
just right in the ecosystem.
So these two things are fighting
against each other a
little bit.
And we tried a lot of things,
from Captain America to
audio-like icons, every
kind of shape.
But finally, we just settled on
the initials GB, because we
really like the name.
And we felt that this
just is enough.
At the top one, we can see the
first icon that we ever
created that had some kind
of a final touch to it.
And then you see how the
icon evolved over time.
And right now, it's pretty much
100% like an Ice Cream
Sandwich, Jelly Bean icon.
So it's a similar thing
with color.
Android is about simplicity,
or beauty and
simplicity, more or less.
And you don't want to have a
lot of colors fighting for
attention, fighting against
each other.
So we just went with basic black
tones, gray tones and
obviously, a couple of white
tones for the phones.
And we are highlighting really
special parts about the
application with this pink,
which is obviously our
branding color.
For example, in that list, you
can see a couple of gigs that
are, more or less, interesting
for you from the
bands that you love.
And they also had one particular
pink line.
That is a gig that is showing
up really close to where you
are right now.
So you probably have more of an
interest than all the other
gigs to you.
So I wanted to talk a little
bit about topography, but I
think Mike has a better
shirt for that part.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Yeah.
I kind of like topography.
So yeah, with GigBeat, in our
early versions, we were really
all over the place.
We had lots of different kind
of designs, different
elements, different buttons.
And it was kind of
wacky, I think.
And we started with the
Eurofurence font up front.
We used this, really,
mostly in headers.
So you can see the top artist
is the only artist that
actually has that font.
And we didn't want
to overuse it.
But we also wanted to get a
little bit of depth into the
application, so we thought
that might work.
But then we realized we were
having some spacing issues.
We realized that letters were
sometimes showing up on top of
each other.
Rendering wasn't working,
really, that great for us, so
we decided to try
another font.
And also the same thing, really,
just a really annoying
problem of rendering.
It really messed with our user
experience, we thought,
because it's important to
see that information.
And if that information is
obscured in any way, it's no
longer relevant for you.
Before Roboto was available,
we decided to use the Droid
Sans as much as possible and,
really, just play around with
the different weights
that were available
to give some depth.
And then, when Roboto
came out, we were so
excited about it.
I'm actually wearing
a Roboto shirt.
We were really excited
about it.
And we decided to just
switch to using
it as much as possible.
You can see we use some
different weights.
The headline font for the list
item is actually a little bit
larger than some of
the other ones.
You'll see on some other slides
we've got some other
really creative ways
we use it.
A dashboard.
Dashboard's a really interesting
pattern.
You've seen it used throughout
Android for a
little while now.
And we tried to figure out how
to use it and be unique.
We wanted to really emphasize
our brand as much as possible.
And the pink is really the
center of it, which is--
I'm color blind, so
that actually does
look pink to me, though.
And the icons are
really unique.
We made sure that we spent lots
of time going over each
individual icon to make sure
they really represented each
section in the best
way possible.
We don't want to drive you to
an artist list when you care
more about locations, or when
you care about artists, seeing
what's all around you right
when you open up the
application.
So we felt, with the amount of
content that we had for the
application, the dashboard
would work
really, really well.
And it also is unique.
We actually, for Mobile World
Congress, had pins made up of
all our dashboard icons, which
was really neat because you
can actually associate the brand
with the part of the app
that, for the most, you'd see
as just pretty basic.
But then, going to the tablet,
we realized, well, you can't
just put four big buttons
onto a 10-inch screen.
That doesn't really work.
So we decided to add as
much fresh content
as we possibly could.
And that's where we decided to
use the larger images to
really bring some color to it,
but also bring some relevant
information.
GUENTHER BEYER: Do we want to
add that the tablet version
isn't working perfectly yet?
MICHAEL NOVAK: It's
kind of work--
yeah, it's awesome.
GUENTHER BEYER: It's OK.
MICHAEL NOVAK: It
looks pretty.
So yeah.
I mean, we didn't actually get
to the dashboard in the
initial version.
The version you see on the left
is a really old version
of the application that has
three tabs with a little
pointer at the bottom.
We were kind of all
over the place.
There's some textures
in there.
And you have to do a lot
of clicking too.
There's some buttons there that
just don't really feel
like they're part of the UI.
Especially, what happens when
that list scrolls up?
All those buttons go away.
So we really wanted
to simplify it.
And so that's how we
ended up coming
to our current dashboard.
We're like, let's really focus
on what are the most important
pieces of our application and
give users the option to dive
into each one of those
as they wish.
ViewPager, it's awesome.
So ViewPager works really well
for us on the phone.
When you click on the Artists
icon from the dashboard, you
get presented with
the list view.
You get to see all your artists
up front, which is
every artist that you follow
inside the application.
You swipe to the right,
you can see Last.fm
recommendations, if you're
a Last.fm user.
And when you swipe to the
left, you actually
see what's near you.
So it basically just cuts out
all of the artists that are
not going to be in your city.
And you basically could see your
entire artist collection,
just by swiping up and down,
left and right, throughout the
entire list.
It feels really great.
And when we went to the tablet,
it didn't exactly work
the same way, because then you
didn't want just really big
lists all over the place.
So we decided to use bigger
images again and do a grid
view with--
what you can't really see on the
phone is a filtered list.
So you could actually
filter through.
We actually list out the
services, so you could just
see what you have from RDO, what
you have from Last.fm.
It gives you some
options there.
Location, location
was really fun.
That took us a while, too.
This is also something we just
didn't get right, which--
it's actually OK to not get
things right the first time.
You really learn a lot from
the whole process.
So it was definitely a learning
process for us.
We have some buttons.
Like you can click a button to
get information that's near
you, which, for us, felt really
awkward, because we can
actually get access to the
GPS and just start
loading data for you.
So why should we have to wait
for you to click the button?
And then also the same
thing for a search.
It was just tucked
right next to it.
And you had to search
for a city.
And this list view would
actually be empty, if you
didn't have any content already
searched for in the
application, which is
also very useful.
So we tried to do some
improvements here.
We added a Search bar, for some
reason, in the screen at
the top of the list.
And then we just decided it
would be really awesome if you
could favorite some of
these locations.
If you're not somebody that
travels very often, you're
going to go back to the same
location over and over again.
So we figured it would be great
to have those right on
the first screen of the Location
section to really get
some easy access.
But it's really empty, if you
don't have any favorites.
You still have to do something
to get content.
So what we decided to do, after
lots of debate, was how
do we get nearby information
and favorite information
together on a screen so that
they could provide as much
useful information without
much interaction?
So we decided, let's pin
the favorites up to
the top of the screen.
And you'll always have
easy access to those.
Those are definitely very
important to you.
But if you've never used the
app before or maybe you
haven't favorited anything yet,
you can still get nearby
information as well.
Or you could be traveling.
Like we're in San Francisco.
So most of my favorites
are in New York.
But if I open up the Location
screen, I can start to see
venues from San Francisco
because it's near by me.
And we were able to do that
all with a segment list.
We were able to create
different sections.
And we thought that that was
the awesome solution out of
all the other ones we were
throwing around.
GUENTHER BEYER: Speaking of
empty screens, you will have
to deal with empty screens
eventually.
There are a lot of apps that are
loading content from the
web and, at times, you just
don't have a web connection.
So how do you deal with
empty screens?
This was the first iteration
of GigBeat's empty screens.
And to be honest, they are
really, really boring and not
really informative.
And we have a lot of those.
And actually we decided that,
if you can't really inform--
because that is obviously what
you want to do in such an
application--
at least entertain to
a certain extent.
You want to have your users
stay within the app and at
least enjoy the empty screens,
even though they aren't really
that beautiful.
And so we created a couple of
really small illustrations and
tried to improve the copy and
just tried to give a certain
feeling across it, a little bit
of fun in between, while
information is loading or while
they have to access some
kind of a log-in or anything
like that.
So we think these turned out
pretty nicely in the overall
context of the application.
MICHAEL NOVAK: The other really
awesome thing we added
was we added some actions
at the bottom.
So when you're on the empty
screen of Last.fm and you
haven't either logged-in
or you don't have any
recommendations, it will
actually say, hey, you can
log-in to Last.fm.
And this screen will populate
with some artists.
So we really tried to take
advantage of as much of the
screen as possible to make it
easy for the user to actually
get benefit from that screen.
GUENTHER BEYER: That's
yours, right?
MICHAEL NOVAK: Right.
Notifications.
So GigBeat, obviously, does a
lot of work for you when you
don't use the application.
But one of the interesting
things that we were playing
with, especially when we were
doing bigger releases, was how
do we let the user know
there's new content?
You might not actually update
the application the first time
you-- you might not use the
application the first
time you update it.
So it could be days or weeks
before you actually
venture into it.
In most cases, you'll
venture into it
because you have a need.
You're trying to get
to certain content.
So we didn't want to just pop
up a dialogue or pop up a
screen that says,
hey, what's new?
By the way, thanks for
using the app.
We wanted to really be as
unobtrusive as possible.
So you can go to
the next slide.
So what we were doing was we'd
actually pop up a notification
for major releases.
I want to emphasize major
releases, because bug fix
updates, like getting a
notification every time you
open the app would be kind
of annoying, I think.
So we wanted to make sure that
we were definitely doing this
just for major--
we've got new features that
we definitely think
you're going to love.
So when you first open the
application, instead of
actually getting in your way and
showing you that Welcome
screen first, we actually just
leave the app the way it is
and pop the notification up.
So that way, once you're done
looking for whatever it is you
came into the app to look for,
you can actually, at your
leisure, check out what we've
got that's new in our
application.
GUENTHER BEYER: We might add
that you have to create about
four sizes and three different
styles for every notification
icon that you are creating.
So be prepared.
MICHAEL NOVAK: This is actually
my favorite feature
that we added in our latest
release that's
on the market today.
We do playback notifications.
So concerts is music, but you're
not always at concerts.
You're listening to music
on the go, commuting.
So it's awesome to find out
about the artist that you're
actually listening to when
you're listening to it.
So what we do here is we pop
up a silent notification
during playback, if that artist
is actually going to be
in your city.
And we do it silently because
the worst thing in the world
would be to pop up a
notification about some
secondary data for the artist
and cause a little beep in the
middle of the song.
That would just frustrate me.
So we wanted to make sure that
we provided the information so
that the user would be notified
that the artist is
coming to their city.
But we didn't want to interrupt
the actual process
that they're doing, which is
listening to the music.
So yeah, we were definitely
being polite, silent
notifications.
And you get the information
without being bothered.
Event details.
So event details
is interesting.
You've got the venue.
They've got the date,
the time, tickets.
It's pretty basic information,
for the most part.
And in our first couple
of iterations,
it was really boring.
We just did a lot of text.
There wasn't really much
breakup in the UI.
There wasn't much color.
I mean, there was really a
lot of the basic colors.
So we decided let's
stick an avatar in
there for the headliner.
And let's throw some icons into
the list to really break
up the flow of all the text.
But it still didn't
seem right.
It felt like it was just
a lot of empty--
the space didn't work for me.
I didn't like this version
very much.
But what you see is
we actually--
go to the next slide---
what you actually see
is bigger pictures.
I love this screen.
This is one of my favorites.
I think I stared at this screen
for 20 minutes when we
actually got it running.
It was amazing.
And so we did a nice
large photo for the
headliner of the event.
And then we added in the
supporting artists as well.
So you'll actually get two
photos there, if there's only
three artists playing.
And then, if there's any more
than three artists, we'll use
that other space to allow
you to click through to
see the full list.
But the event date is actually
really awesome, because this
is where we were able to use
various weights of Roboto to
really drive the emphasis on
the date, where we do the
actual day in a large, thinner
font, and then the rest of the
date in a smaller,
bolder font.
Which was a nice break up from
the other text that comes
below the photos.
We were able to put the venue
information, check-in
capabilities, and
getting tickets.
And then, on the tablet screen,
we had some room to
throw some more photos in,
some more information.
And we actually had the list
right on the side, so you
could just go through each of
the different events and see
the information right
next to it.
GUENTHER BEYER: If you're
thinking about this
application, I think this
is about events.
This is about live music.
And live music is
exciting, right?
These screens were not
really that exciting.
They're pretty boring.
But I think we figured
it out pretty
nicely with these screens.
Because these photos, they
actually are exciting.
You actually want to see
these guys live, right?
OK, the next one's the
artist details.
And I think you will love this
one as well, because the old
version of GigBeat, it just had
a list of-- well, it had
the artist name and
then a list of its
gigs that were upcoming.
And we wanted to add a little
bit more to these screens.
So I sketched up this pretty
rough thing here.
And I showed it to Mike.
And he really liked it.
But he hated it at the same
time, I guess, because--
fun fact--
Marco here is the creator of
that BeautifulPeople's
People's app from Android 4.0.
And we wanted to do something
similar with
that carousel slider.
And they can swipe from
left to right
and from top to bottom.
As it turned out, that
code was just
working for Android 4.0.
And GigBeat is supporting
2.1 and upwards.
So that poor guy over there had
to rewrite that whole code
to make it work on
all the systems.
MICHAEL NOVAK: It took a couple
of weeks, but it was
well worth it.
It's one of my other favorite
screens in the application.
And we were really able to--
the list looks great.
You've got nice, big photos.
We were able to break up--
The other part of the problem
was we couldn't figure out how
to get other artist information,
like a bio, in
with the tour dates.
The previous screen showed the
avatar, the artist's name and
a star, and then the
list of events.
So it's like we didn't want you
to have to click to get to
a profile and then click to get
back to the events, so we
were really trying to figure out
the best way to do that.
And this was just perfect.
When I saw the Contacts
application and then the
sketches, it was the
perfect solution.
You're able to swipe
back and forth.
There's no pause at a screen
going backward or forward.
It really worked perfectly,
I think.
GUENTHER BEYER: You want
to add something
for the icon set?
MICHAEL NOVAK: Yes.
So we actually have an icon
set available as well at
androidicons.com.
So every application that we've
been working on, all the
icons that we put into them,
we're actually just putting
into this set.
It's how we met, actually, was
Guenther put out an icon set
that I took advantage of for
some open source applications.
Because as a developer,
I don't really
design icons very well.
I know which icons I like in
certain places, but I can't
design them.
So it's a really great resource
for developers.
I recommend everybody
check it out.
MARCO PAGLIA: That's it?
Thanks.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: So I have a
question for the crowd.
Who does think that the Square
application and the GigBeat
application look the same?
No one.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Nobody.
MARCO PAGLIA: As you see, you
have so many ways to make your
application unique.
It's just beautiful.
I'd like to ask a question
to our guests
here, just as a start.
Then we can get to
the audience and
to our group here.
Let me get them a microphone.
How do you come up
with that color?
MICHAEL NOVAK: Well,
I'm color blind.
So I'm going to throw that
one right to you.
GUENTHER BEYER: Please
ask again.
I didn't catch that.
MARCO PAGLIA: How did you
come up with that color?
GUENTHER BEYER: That color?
I'm not quite sure, man.
It just looks good, right?
Does it?
About choosing color, there's
just some kind of gut feeling.
There's not a lot about it.
As I said, you don't want to
have a lot of color fighting
for attention and fighting
[INAUDIBLE].
Well, for example, the Google
logo has four colors, which is
a little bit too much.
[LAUGHTER]
GUENTHER BEYER: But well, in
the end, you really want to
keep down the amount of colors
and just select some for
highlights.
And we just thought
that one for
highlights would be enough.
And I think a pinkish,
reddish thing is
a pretty good highlight.
MICHAEL NOVAK: It took
a little while for
me to get used it.
When I first saw it,
I was like, whoa.
Wow, that's different.
And then, once I started using
it, and I was like, wow, this
is amazing, because it added
just enough color to
really stand out.
And in certain places, like in
the carousel slider, it's the
thick header, and it's
the thin line
underneath the pictures.
It really adds a lot to it.
MARCO PAGLIA: OK, we have a
long line of questions.
Let's try to get to them.
AUDIENCE: Two very short ones.
Why dashboard pattern, instead
of action bar lists?
MICHAEL NOVAK: So we actually
developed this application
when, I think, it was Froyo or
Gingerbread was available.
So the action bar pattern, we're
still really developing,
which is why I think the
initial version really
emphasizes on dashboard.
We decided not to change that
because we felt that those
four icons really stood to our
brand and the message we're
trying to send with
our application.
And we really were able to have
fun with those icons.
And we only had four, so we felt
like it worked for us, in
particular.
GUENTHER BEYER: Can I add that
there is a lot of hate going
on about the dashboard right
now, because a lot of people
think that a dashboard,
in general, is bad.
But a dashboard makes a lot of
sense, if you have a couple of
distinct pieces of information
that are--
but there is not one single one
that is more important.
So I think a dashboard makes a
lot of sense, especially in
that context.
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah.
I just think, with the list, it
allows you to put featured
content right up front as
soon as you get into the
application.
But everybody has reasons.
The other thing was using
notifications when the
application's updated.
Do you find that
spammy at all?
Or why not just a banner when
they open the application
after an update or something?
MICHAEL NOVAK: So we didn't
actually think of a banner.
But in terms of spammy,
our major updates
don't come very often.
We're not like every time we
update and say, hey, we
changed that text so that
it's spelled correctly.
Or that crash that you noticed,
we fixed that.
It's like that stuff's in the
market listing, so we decided
let's not use the notifications
for that.
But when we have a lot of big
features, like a redesign, we
added some bio information,
that's stuff that, I think, is
pretty important.
And it comes once every couple
of months, really, I think.
AUDIENCE: OK, good.
Thanks.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Do you use GPS
or course location?
MICHAEL NOVAK: So we actually
use course.
We don't really need fine
location, because most of the
information from the API side
of things is metro areas.
So we don't need that
much from the GPS.
AUDIENCE: So I installed
that app to follow
along with you guys.
And it looked pretty good.
I was curious on if you guys
plan on integrating Google
Music with it in the
future, though.
MICHAEL NOVAK: That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: Because I saw that
stuff in Drop box and a couple
of other methods for it.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Yeah.
That's like the email that I've
gotten the most ever, I
think, was, where's Google
Music support?
And as soon as there's an
official way for us to get to
the Artists list-- because
right now, the content
provider on the device
doesn't return your
Google Music artists--
once that's actually available
for us, we want to
dive in and do it.
But we don't really want to try
and hack it, because then,
if it breaks or if there's
something else going on, we
really don't want to break
the user experience.
We feel like that might
be more frustrating.
So we decided to stay
away from it.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Look forward to it.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: In terms of user
experience and design, how do
you deal with all
their platforms?
Do you think it's better to
style everything to have the
same user experience across
other devices as well?
Or do you leverage whatever the
platform is offering you?
For instance, take the example
of dialogs or edit text or
check boxes, do you have
the same style for all?
Or how do you deal with that?
MICHAEL NOVAK: For GigBeat, we
style the dialogues, but we
use wherever the platform
base is.
So for Holo, we use the Holo
dialogue as a base.
And for Gingerbread and lower,
we use the regular theme as a
dialogue base.
And we do change the color.
But we didn't port back a lot
of the drawable assets like
the progress bar or the progress
indicator, we just
used whatever is on
the platform for
that particular device.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
ERIC BURKE: I actually
wanted to mention
something about that.
One thing you're going to find
is, once you start customizing
one thing, you are all-in.
Just as an example, some of the
Motorola phones that are
using Motorola's skin, we found
that we had tweaked the
button color, but we didn't
tweak the text color.
So we ended up with
white on white.
So once you start messing with
customizations in the theme,
you pretty much have to
customize everything.
Otherwise, you're going to get
some nasty surprises when you
go to some of the
carrier skins.
AUDIENCE: So your color
scheme is great.
You guys used pink and shades
of gray to really make your
app look distinctive.
But you also have a very
picture-heavy app with the
artist pics and everything
like that.
And they come in with
their own colors.
And since these are musical
artists, they're likely to be
loud, possibly obnoxious colors,
which could conflict
with the ones that you have,
with your pink and grays.
So have you guys put
any thought into
that sort of issue?
And is there anything
you can do to try to
reduce that loud contrast?
GUENTHER BEYER: Well, yeah.
That is because we turned down
about every color, except for
these really, really important
highlights.
Because then these colors don't
interfere with each other.
And if you're having a lot of
pictures, then you might not
need any color at all, right?
So but if there is still one or
two really important marks
within the UI, then you might
highlight them, except that
color that you have
used throughout
all the other screens.
And that is pink, in our case.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Yeah, it's
definitely an accent color.
So really, it's meant
to emphasize certain
parts of the UI.
And it's really carefully used,
I think, throughout the
application for that reason.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Sure.
AUDIENCE: This is a question for
both GigBeat and Square.
I noticed that your application
supports a variety
of Android versions and also
a wide variety of screen
resolutions.
Would you like to share with
us your experiences in
supporting multiple versions of
Androids and also different
hardware specs?
Thank you.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Sure.
It was certainly a challenge at
the beginning, because we
were trying to figure
out what all these
differences really were.
But what it came down to is
there's a lot of resources
available to abstract away
some of those different
nuances, like when things
get deprecated.
For example, some of the
notification stuff was
deprecated in how
you create it.
The action bar is certainly
something that's introduced in
Honeycomb, and is not available
on Gingerbread.
So we really tried to abstract
away as much of the resources
as possible, so we could plug
them in where they made sense.
Different static classes to
lazy-load APIs that are
available on newer devices
versus older.
It's the same thing with layout
resources for different
screen sizes.
We took advantage of values
files and the dimensions file
to actually keep all of our
dimensions there, so that our
layouts weren't repetitive.
And that allowed us to scale
pretty easily, without a lot
of work and testing and really
having to worry about if we
changed the right file or not
and made the size correct.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
I was wondering if you had any
plans to open source the
Contacts implementation
that you had written.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Actually, yeah.
That was a slide.
And then I got really busy.
So yeah, it--
GUENTHER BEYER: I forgot that.
Sorry.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Yeah, we are
actually planning to open up
the modifications that we made
to get that to run back to
2.1, hopefully, in the
next couple of weeks.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Where can
I look for that?
MICHAEL NOVAK: Probably--
GUENTHER BEYER: I think you
might want to follow one of
our Google+ streams, because
we have so many.
But we are cross-sharing
as much as possible.
MICHAEL NOVAK: Yeah.
GUENTHER BEYER: Which
will eventually--
MICHAEL NOVAK: Definitely, one
of the ones that's on the
screen now, or one of
our personal ones.
We'll be spamming that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, a lot.
MARCO PAGLIA: OK,
last question.
AUDIENCE: I really love what you
guys did with the tablet
landing screen.
You have the dashboard--
MICHAEL NOVAK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --features and
the content there.
So my question is also for
the Android design team.
Does the dashboard still work
on tablets, considering you
only have just icons?
MICHAEL NOVAK: As far as GigBeat
goes, I think it
worked out quite nicely.
It allowed us to use big
pictures and take up the
majority of the screen for
content, but still have those
dashboard items.
Instead of a grid, just list
it on the right-hand side.
So I think, if the method fits
for the application and it
works for the implementation
that you have, you can get
pretty creative with the ways
to actually make it work.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
I think that's the
right answer.
In the tablet, instead of having
this dedicated screen
that serves that navigation
function, you can just divide
the real estate up and have a
panel that is the emotional or
logical peer to it,
but presents it
in a different way.
It doesn't have to be
the four up pattern.
You can actually do
lots of different
things in that space.
MICHAEL NOVAK: One of the
takeaways that we had with
developing GigBeat was there's
a lot of creativity.
You can do a lot of interesting
things.
And we follow the patterns just
about as much as possible.
I think I'm probably annoying
at sometimes when I'm like,
oh, that's not exactly right.
We should do it this way.
Or my implementation isn't
exactly pretty enough.
So there's a lot of going
back and forth.
But as you can see, we really
emphasize trying to find as
much creativity without making
the application foreign for
the users of the device.
GUENTHER BEYER: Yeah.
Maybe that's why we showed a
couple of these sketches in
the early prototypes.
And the application evolved over
time because there was
not really one pattern for
a good user experience.
But you have to try
out a couple of
those as much as possible.
Do some sketching.
Do some real prototyping.
Do some wireframings.
And then, eventually, you will
find a good solution.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MARCO PAGLIA: OK, let's give a
round of applause to GigBeat.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: All right.
This is where things become
interesting now.
We're going to have
this workshop.
And we never tried it before, so
you'll have to bear with us
a little bit.
But this is what we're
going to do.
We'll have five developers that
are going to be coming up
on stage one at a time.
They're going to have one minute
to just run us through
their application, just to have
a little bit of context.
[LAUGHTER]
MARCO PAGLIA: And for that,
we brought the gong.
[RINGS GONG]
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: Put out
for the gong.
Thank you, gong.
And yeah, let's try to keep
the atmosphere informal.
We really want to have
interesting discussions with
these applications.
And hopefully, we're going
to get some nice
questions as well.
So let's start with
the first one.
The first one is going to
be Droid of the Day.
And I'm going to get here
on stage Mike Wolfson.
Please, give a round
of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: Let me
get my slides on.
MIKE WOLFSON: So good morning,
good afternoon, I guess.
My name is Mike Wolfson.
My app is Droid of the Day.
The concept is designed
to be simple.
And the app is designed
Basically, it is a App of the
Day app that every day you get
a notification of a app that is
hand-picked either by me or
with help from my community.
You can choose to
check it out.
Or you can exit out.
This is the home screen.
If you choose to check
out an app, you will
just launch the app.
And we'll, obviously, go into
this in more detail.
I don't make any money on the
app, which is probably a
business model familiar to a
lot of people in this room.
It's just something
I do for fun.
I did want to mention one of the
reasons that I do this is
to highlight great developers
and to filter good apps up
that might not be visible
in the market.
So if you're in the room and you
would like me to feature
your app, just send
me an email to
droidoftheday@gmail.com.
Put hash tag I/O 12, or
something in there, so I know
where you came from.
But I'm always looking for
great apps to feature.
And I think that's
under a minute.
RICHARD FULCHER:
That was good.
Thank you.
Thank you, very much.
MIKE WOLFSON: Thank you.
MARCO PAGLIA: So which screen
do you want to start from?
RICHARD FULCHER: Let's just
do the first screen.
Yeah.
So this is kind of
the high wire act
portion of the program.
So we're just going to walk
through some of the
screens of the app.
We're going to talk about things
we like and things that
we think, maybe, could be
improved a little bit from the
design standpoint.
I've got the mic here.
But we've got a mic
in the back row
for the other designers.
And we're just going to make
this a little Wild West,
loosey-goosey.
So I wanted to start by just
talking about a few of the
things I really like about
this application.
And first and foremost--
maybe, Marco, if you could
advance one slide--
this app has a real voice.
The Droid of the Day comment
that comes in when you go and
look at a particular application
is very editorial,
very genuine, very human.
And that's something that's
actually pretty important in
an app like this.
It's not just a piece
of market speak.
I know you're hoping, maybe,
you could get out of San
Francisco without getting this
hippy-dippy emotional crap.
But it's actually really handy
to go to an app that's
actually expressing an opinion
that isn't just some of the
market speak that you may
have experienced in the
last couple of days.
So I really like that.
I really like how the app
is very tightly focused.
It's not today's app in six
different categories.
It doesn't ask a lot
from the user.
The user doesn't need to
remember to check it.
He will get a notification
reminder when
a new app is available.
They don't feel obliged
to come every day, if
they don't have to.
There's a History view that
they can dig back through.
They can choose to consume it on
a weekly basis instead, if
they prefer.
And it's got ways for
them to interact.
They can rate the content.
They can make suggestions,
as we saw before.
So I think all of those
are really great
things in the app.
So good job.
Great.
MIKE WOLFSON: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE WOLFSON: But.
RICHARD FULCHER: But.
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD FULCHER: No, no no.
So let's go back one slide.
Let's go back to
the dashboard.
I know we talked about
the dashboard in
GigBeat's context as well.
And I think this might be an
opportunity where we can even
play that focus aspect
a little bit more
strongly for the app.
I think you've got two
operations here, which are
really important, the Today's
app, which you naturally want
to drive users to very directly,
and the history is
really important too.
But I think a lot of the
other ones could
possibly be put into--
if you were to adapt the action
bar pattern, they can
go into the Overflow menu.
And maybe you could just bypass
the need to even have
this dashboard, and just drive
right to the Droid of the Day.
Rachel, I know in your talk this
morning you were talking
about what's the hero
screen of your app.
This seems like a good
example of that.
That Droid App page should
be the hero.
And it should be the first
thing you get to.
So on the next screen,
we've got--
this screen is the type of
screen that I always find
challenging, because just
the amount of content.
And the content has value.
It's not noise content.
You're really just trying to
deliver all the things the
user could want to know about
this application into one
piece of canvas.
And I think you get a lot
of things really right.
The most important content is
at the top of the screen.
And generally, the less
important stuff goes down.
And I really especially like
how you're using the
collapse-expand for the
market description.
That's a block of text that you
don't really have a good
sense how long that's
going to be.
So using that control there
fixes it in place.
A user can dig into it, but it
doesn't disrupt getting at the
other important stuff that's
lower on the screen.
One thing--
if you can go to the
next slide, Marco--
that same control winds
up getting used
for the screen shots.
Can you put your device
on the bed again?
You get to see just a
little bit of a peek
of the screen shots.
And you can actually interact
with that peek.
If they're multiple, you
could scroll or swipe
through that region.
And then you can expand it up
to open up and walk through
the screen shots that way.
I think, for the screen shots,
it's probably best to just
expand them all the time.
You know they're going to take
up some height, but it's a
fixed amount of height, unlike
the market example where, I
think, it makes perfect sense
to use that expand control.
So I would consider, maybe,
just moving away from that
control and just showing them at
full height the whole time.
The other thing that's really
kind of interesting to think
about on this screen are
all of the actions.
And again, this is
a challenge.
So you've got the ability to
rate, to download, to share it
with others.
I think you probably want to
pick one of those actions to
be the primary action
on the screen.
And it's probably the
Download button.
To your credit, you give that
to a user in a couple of
different ways.
They can tap on the App icon
at the top to install it.
Or they can hit the Download
button, which is above the
fold, so it's visible
on the device.
But I think you could probably
make it even
a little bit stronger.
I'm going to just do some
wireframing here.
Let's see.
So one thing you can think
about would be--
I always draw an action bar
before I draw anything else.
I'm just hardwired to do that
at this point my life.
You might be able to take that
Download button and move it up
more tightly with
the App icon.
Instead of having those two
functions that do the same
thing, if you just make this
whole top area a target.
If this is the name of
the app, we've got
the big icon there.
Maybe we have the Download
button--
Marco, this is actually very
similar to a lot of the stuff
that you're doing in
the Play Store.
MARCO PAGLIA: Mm-hm.
RICHARD FULCHER: You could even
have the price be part of
that Download button.
And you present it there.
Just to make that top part of
the screen, here's the app,
here's how to get it.
If you don't even need to read
anything more about it, or if
the notification told
you enough, hop in.
Get it.
And you're on your way.
MIKE WOLFSON: Is there any
way to represent--
for the icon, I have that
as a clickable point.
Is there any visual
representation of some way
that I can inform the
user that that
is, in fact, clickable?
It's just an image.
They don't necessarily know.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
That's something we struggle
with a little bit, too.
For something like when we do
quick contacts, we decorate it
a little bit in one of the
corners, just to hint that
this is something that isn't
just a graphic element.
The other thing you can
do is you could just--
the way that you wrap
that space.
And maybe it's less about
turning the image specifically
into a target, and more about
this whole area is a target
and the action associated
with it.
MIKE WOLFSON: Yeah, that's what
comes to mind is I just
make that whole area
clickable as a--
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
MIKE WOLFSON: That view.
RICHARD FULCHER: Cool.
A couple of other things, just
on this screen, really quick.
Now that I've taken Download and
moved it away from Share,
we need to think about
what to do with that.
A pattern you could consider
would be to use the Share
Pack, which is something that
goes in the action bar and is
a two-target action.
It's got the generic Share icon,
which brings up the list
of all the different other apps
that you can call out to
do this share.
And that's the current
behavior.
And it also brings in just
a shortcut to the
most recently used.
So if the user just always
shares via Twitter or Facebook
or Google+--
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD FULCHER: --then
you're in great shape.
I think the only other thing I
want to talk about on that
screen is at the very bottom
of the screen.
So maybe if you go to the next
slide, Marco, there is--
oops, sorry.
previous.
Yeah, down at the very tail of
that screen, there are the
Rate buttons.
And I think that's a really
great feature.
And I like that you're trying to
use color to differentiate
between the positive and
the negative actions.
Peter, do you have any thoughts
on the visual side of
how he could treat those Like
and Dislike buttons?
PETER INGHAM: Oh, yeah.
Part of this app, what I really
like, is that you have
multiple themes.
And it's always hard to
be a visual designer.
And the way you have to do it
is it's easy to include
everything and have
multiple themes.
But what you really need to do
it on is figure out your
brand, and then just go
with that one theme.
So you have colorful
gradients.
You have brushed metal and these
luster, shiny icons.
And I'm wondering if you could
actually take what you did in
the dashboard with those icons,
those metal icons, and
explore that theme and made that
the focus of everything.
And that Today's app would
become a chrome icon, too.
And then, maybe, your action bar
could be chromed out, too.
You create this illusion
of life that it doesn't
necessarily mean that everything
becomes a bookshelf
or anything like you mimic
the real world.
But it actually means that you
create these elements and you
establish these relationships
where they could actually live
in the same world together.
And then people aren't--
a constant analogy I always have
is that like I just saw
Prometheus, the sci-fi movie.
And when I see aliens, I'm
totally freaked out.
But then, an hour later, I'm
like, oh, this is just a
really cruel, weird world that
these monsters live in.
And I'm not freaked
out any more.
So once you start establishing
these relationships with icons
and the elements and, as a user,
when you enter it and
you realize that these things
can actually have a
relationship, it's
a nice feeling.
You don't feel like you're
shocked every single time you
turn a page or enter a new
state of the page.
MIKE WOLFSON: So to just
recapture that, what you
suggest is I capture in those,
Like, Dislike buttons, some
sort of iconography that matches
the rest of the icons,
to create that common language
through the app.
PETER INGHAM: Right.
RICHARD FULCHER: Great.
Thanks, Peter.
PETER INGHAM: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: If I could, I
wanted to crash the party and
mention one other thing.
Like these guys, I really
like the app.
And I'm actually really
excited to see all the
changes, all these suggestions
come in.
If you could go to the next
slide, Marco, the detail view.
There's one thing here that I
think is worth talking about.
This is one of my personal,
pet crusades.
I always talk about this, which
is the sometimes less is
actually more.
And I have two different types
of wars that I like to wage.
And one is a war against text
junk, the unnecessary
typographic elements that are
intended to clarify things,
but where, actually, space and
contrast and color actually
make a better impact.
And also label junk, where,
again, context can provide
much of the same function.
So one of the things I'd suggest
you might think about
is, when you look at all those
section headings, they're very
effective as section headings,
because you've used the color
contrast, so they don't all
need to have that colon
following them.
Again, when you have things like
the cost of the app or
the size or the rating, you
might not even need to have
labels on many of those things,
because the data
itself can carry that context.
You represent the rating
as stars, maybe.
And then, again, it becomes
very obvious what it is.
So take a look throughout all
your apps and think about
which elements are really
just gilding the lily.
You'll find that taking them out
allows you to really focus
more on the content.
MIKE WOLFSON: That's
a really good idea.
That will allow me to recapture
some of that space,
also, that is so valuable.
That's a really great
feedback.
MALE SPEAKER: Sorry to crash,
but that was just one of my
pet things.
RICHARD FULCHER: OK, I'm going
to let you finish.
MARCO PAGLIA: And with that,
I'm honored to--
[GONG SOUNDS]
MARCO PAGLIA: Thank you.
Thank you, Mike.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah,
thank you, Mike.
MIKE WOLFSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: All right.
The second application we're
going to see today is Papyrus.
And I'm happy to welcome up
on stage, Andrew Hughes.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW HUGHES: My voice
isn't that loud.
So this is Papyrus.
It is a natural handwriting
note-taking application.
I designed it initially
for 10-inch tablets.
And we're slowly trying to work
the interface down to
smaller devices.
So this is running on
a ThinkPad tablet.
How many people know what active
pen technology is?
A few people.
OK.
So natural handwriting is--
basically, this app allows you
to write just like you would
write on paper, but with all
of the advantages of modern
technology, like in tablets.
So with an active pen--
thank you-- that comes with this
device, it's different
than a capacitive stylus that
works on just any tablet.
It's a lot more accurate.
And it has a lot more
data throughput.
It can detect when it's near
the device, pressure
sensitive, it has
side buttons.
Others have more side buttons.
So for example, if I open a
note here, I can write.
And it works really
well with me.
So if I have it bigger, you
can see the pressure
sensitivity there.
So it allows for a much more
natural handwriting.
So basically, the application
has notebooks on the left and
notes on the right.
And that's about it.
[GONG SOUNGS]
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: All right,
thank you, Andrew.
Let's see.
So when you wrote to us, you
were asking us about the
general navigation.
It feels like having to have
this navigation with a
split-screen, it's kind of
challenging on smaller devices.
And I thought it was a very
interesting point.
In fact, actually, also I was
excited when you applied for
this workshop, because I do
use this application.
And the beauty of this
application is that it's all
about gestures.
You have two fingers.
You move your canvas
with two fingers.
You pinch the zoom.
You control with your pen.
You can erase with
your finger.
It's just beautiful.
And then I felt, maybe, a way
to get this kind of screen,
the split-screen, to work on
different devices, on smaller
screens could be to maybe having
it slide like a lot of
applications do today.
But then, at the same time,
I wonder whether
there are other options.
Like maybe you don't need
the split-screen at all.
Why don't we make
the navigation
to be purely gestural.
So that, when I get
my application,
I see all my notebooks.
And then I tap on them.
And they open up in all
the pages that I have.
And perhaps I can pinch to
get back to my notebooks.
And everything just becomes
super gestural.
So that's something that I think
we need to consider.
Not every application must have
a split-screen or this
standard navigation.
I think we can really innovate
in the way we get into
different views.
I guess the pattern that we
already have, which is similar
to what I'm talking about,
this gallery, where the
navigation is purely
hierarchical, you don't have
any split-screen.
Tell me what you think
about that.
ANDREW HUGHES: Yeah,
I want to utilize
gestures as much as possible.
So with a pen right now--
I know you were talking about
the general layout of the
app-- but in the note taking,
you can use gestures to undo.
So if I draw something and I
flick left to undo and then
flick right as redo, flick up
to get to the color palette.
So things like that allow
for quick navigation.
You can also access those things
just by clicking from
the action bar.
But definitely adding more
gestures to be able to
navigate around the rest
of the app as well.
I was talking to Roman Nurik.
And he suggested, instead of
having buttons to switch
between pages like that, to use
a bezel swipe to switch
between pages in the note, which
I think is a great idea.
MARCO PAGLIA: That's great,
because I swear I haven't
talked to Roman.
But that was part of my
next suggestions.
ANDREW HUGHES: [LAUGHS]
MARCO PAGLIA: I swear.
Maybe we just think
the same way.
There was another point you
were bringing in you
application, which is all
of these elements
on the action bar.
And obviously, when
you get to smaller
screens, they get stacked.
So I should have a screen shot
somewhere about that.
And then you tend to cover
the bottom action
bar with your hand.
And things don't
get so usable.
So maybe even here, just like
Roman was suggesting, an
option can be do we really need
all those actions on the
action bar?
Again, how we can
bring gestures.
How can we innovate
with gestures?
I think the reason why we
selected the Papyrus
application here is really
because innovating with
gestures is one of the things
that Android, I believe, is
doing the best.
We have swiping gestures.
We have edge gestures.
We have a lot of things that
we're introducing.
And I think Papyrus can really
help to push the agenda here.
So one thing is what Roman
was mentioning.
So maybe add gestures to swipe
from one page to another, just
like Chrome introduced,
the Chrome browser.
And then, when I see the Undo
buttons, I'm thinking, I wish
there was a universal
way to do Undo.
We just haven't found it yet.
But I'm sure that, with your
contribution, with your ideas,
with more applications finding
out the right gesture for
those patterns, we're going
to crack it at some point.
And at that point, we
won't need buttons
any more for Undo.
I really see how Papyrus, at
some point, will be just,
literally, a piece of paper that
you can navigate with.
So I don't know if other people
have some feelings
around the action bar
and these buttons.
The crowd has been silent
in the last few minutes.
if you guys want to ask
questions to Andrew, just feel
free to stand up and come on.
ANDREW HUGHES: So on the
previous slide, we've had a
lot of users complain
about having the
buttons on the bottom.
I put them there because
I didn't really know
what else to do.
They wouldn't fit in the top,
so I put them on the bottom.
But when you're writing,
especially, it's kind of
harder with a Galaxy note,
because it's not
that big of a device.
But when you're writing,
your hand hits those.
And the other problem is the
physical capacitive buttons
that are already
on the device.
People who are left-handed
hit the Back button.
People who are right-handed
hit the Menu button.
And there's not really a good
way to get around that.
MARCO PAGLIA: Well, it's
kind of what we
discussed here, right.
If you can avoid having,
exposed, the two arrows to go
from one page to another,
that's going
to reduce your elements.
Of course, you probably still
want to give that navigation
in a more findable way.
Maybe you can have it in
the overflow menu.
But I think there are ways for
you to probably end up having
maybe half of these actions.
RICH FULCHER: We also have--
You might be able to take a
cue from what some of the
media apps do.
Where, once you're in a hangout,
once you're watching
a video, we actually dismiss
the action bar.
Now for you, it might just
be a different queue
that you would use.
Maybe it's when Stylus
is down.
Just take the bars away, and
maybe wait for that lift off.
Then they can come back on.
Because you're never going to
need to activate any of them
while you're actually in the
sketching mode to output.
So maybe a trick like that
might be valuable, too.
MARCO PAGLIA: And there's one
more thing that I wanted to
talk to you about, which is this
other problem that you
were facing, the color picker.
And the problem is, when you
get to a small screen, this
color picker doesn't seem
to work anymore.
Now there are ways to do it.
For instance, in the book
application, what we do, in
smaller screen we do put a tab,
a swipeable tab, to go
from one arrow to another.
So you could see that
happening here.
But even there, I think you can
push the agenda and really
try something new.
The color pickers, they were
designed for mice and for
different kinds of
interaction.
So I don't know the right
interaction is.
After I saw that, I started
thinking about it.
And I'm not sure if I can draw
on this directly, I can try.
So it works beautifully.
So maybe, you have
this icon here.
And when you tap it, instead of
getting to a grid like this
one, maybe you just have
the main colors.
Like, if it were flowers
and you have all the
tones around them.
And then, maybe when you hold
press on them, perhaps you
could zoom in a square, and then
moving your finger left
and right will change that
ratio and intensity.
The point really is, sometimes
it's not really about putting
the right action bar, or putting
in the right tabs.
It's really about rethinking
the problem.
And when we do it, I think
we really could--
when we can crack the problem
with different solutions, I
think we really contribute
to the system to
evolve and to be better.
So my recommendation would be,
can we find a beautiful way to
have a color picker, which is
also gestural, uses the
capacity of a touch screen,
and so forth?
One question and I think we
have to play the gong.
AUDIENCE: Because you were
talking about the
undo gesture earlier.
On a lot of your computers,
you're starting to switch to
having purely gesture-based
trackpads.
And often, two fingers swiping
to the left would be going
back, or vice versa,
to the right.
And so maybe you could do
something like that.
And maybe even for changing
pages, you could do, like,
three fingers.
So I don't know if that helps.
ANDREW HUGHES: Yeah, currently
in Papyrus, we use two fingers
to scroll and pinch to zoom.
Because you can use a single
finger to erase.
And that's because you can
detect the difference between
the pen and the finger.
But definitely some gesture
like that--
like I said, you can use the pen
side button, currently, in
our application, to undo and
redo by performing gestures
that won't work on non-active
pen devices.
MARCO PAGLIA: It is a very
interesting problem to
investigate, and I wish
you the best.
So--
ANDREW HUGHES: Thank you.
MARCO PAGLIA: --round of
applause for Papyrus.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: We didn't
have to play the gong.
So the next application coming
on stage is Equalizer.
And I'm happy to welcome, on
stage, Michael Moussa.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL MOUSSA: Hi, I'm Michael
Moussa, and this is
Alex Rocha.
We are the founders of
Smart Android Apps.
And the Equalizer app is a
global equalizer app that
works with any third-party
music player.
So I'm just going to get
into it and show you
a typical use case.
First of all, you would open up
your favorite music player,
whatever it may be.
In my case, Google Play Music.
And you'd play your song.
And from there, you can
then open up our app.
We have a convenient shortcut
and a notification bar.
But Google Play Music also has
this nice, open intent--
well, Android intent, it's
in API framework.
We go sound effects.
And from there, I can change
with one of the standard
presets, or go to the equalizer
tab, either by
touching or swiping, and
then changing them by
hand, just like that.
And that's pretty much the gist
of how to use the app.
There are other, more advanced
features as well.
So from there, I think we
can go to the slides.
[GONG SOUNDS]
JENS NAGLE: So, yeah, guys.
First of all-- and we talked a
little bit before the session
today started--
I was really happy that you guys
applied for this session,
because I got to know your app,
and I already use it.
And one feature that I find
especially cool is, they
actually use ID3 tags in the
MP3s to automatically switch
between presets.
And that actually works quite
well, especially if you're in
the car and you don't want to
fiddle around with your phone.
So I really like it
and I use it.
One thing I wanted to
talk about is--
and that might affect other
applications, as well, as far
as I see it in the market--
is actually the tutorial.
So everybody can see, this is
actually the extent of the
first use tutorial.
It's like one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
eight screens.
What prompted you to have that
tutorial at the beginning?
MICHAEL MOUSSA: Alex did it,
so he can talk about it.
ALEX ROCHA: Way to
blame me, huh?
To be honest, we were having a
lot of issues with support.
One of the things was, a lot of
our users actually thought
that our application was a music
app, a music player.
And that's not really true.
What our app is there for is to
complement the music player.
Again, you use any music player
you want, whether it be
the standard music player app,
doubleTwist, whatever
the case may be.
Then you open our app, and then
that's when you start
applying some of the presets,
equalizer effects,
virtualizer, bass booster,
you name it.
We were getting tons and tons
of emails on, hey guys--
well, emails and one stars.
So we actually said, we're
going to come up
with a guided tour.
It's going to be, hopefully,
enough so that users can
actually learn how to use our
app properly, reduce the
number of support emails we were
getting, and hopefully
get those ratings
up and going.
That was, primarily, the
reason why we did it.
JENS NAGLE: And I can see how
that is sort of a difficult
balance to strike.
So especially, you have a little
bit of a more techy
app, in that it's not the
sort of traditional app.
It's sort of a helper app for
other music applications.
So there's probably
a little bit more
explanation necessary there.
But as I said, it's a difficult
balance to strike.
If you get too lengthy, though,
I think you run the
real risk that you're really
not achieving what you're
setting out to do here.
Because users are often not
very patient people.
I would venture to say that,
after the second or the third
screen, you would probably
have the
yada, yada, yada, yada.
And then, on the
final screen--
they just skip over content.
More general, and not
necessarily geared towards
your app, because I think you
can possibly benefit from th
tutorial, but I see many apps
on market where, sometimes I
ask myself, do they really
need a tutorial.
Either the UI is already so
self-explanatory that maybe
the tutorial is not needed.
And that is what I would
probably give as advice in
general, is try to make it
work without a tutorial.
Try to test it with users.
Do they really need a tutorial
or does your UI cover it?
Does the UI speak for
itself, basically.
The other good outcome of such a
test is that, if you do find
out that they have problems,
you find out which
problems they are.
And that is probably something
that you could zero in on.
Cherry pick the problems.
What are really the problems
that you need to address, or
the information that you need to
give to users, in order to
get over to the initial hump To
Understand what your app is
about and how it interplays
with other apps?
MICHAEL MOUSSA: What
are your thoughts
on, like, Toast hints?
I've seen certain apps, in
certain areas, put Toast hint.
Maybe the first time, or after
they detect that you're doing
something which they may feel
wrong a couple times, like the
swipe app, for instance.
They use a lot of Toast hints.
JENS NAGLE: Personally, not
a big fan of Toast.
What do you guys think, Marco?
MARCO PAGLIA: You're putting
me on the spot.
I think, like for everything,
any information that we can
avoid to provide and it's just
implicit in what you're doing,
the better.
I can see Toast being overused,
just when the UI's
not confident that it's going
to do a good job.
And it feels the same with
tutorials, as well.
You do them because you don't
know if, really, people are
going to get it.
It's kind of philosophical, but
obviously the less you use
Toast, the less you use
tutorial, the more, probably,
you're going to be putting a lot
of emphasis in the UI, in
the application, and making all
the things clear through
hierarchies, and through
use cases and so forth.
So it is a tough call.
RACHEL GARB: Yeah, and another
thing is that, remember that
these first time tutorials in
Toast and stuff, they're
actually interruptions, right.
It's not something that
the user asked for.
And chances are, because
of that, they might
not even pay attention.
And so they might see it as
an annoyance, quickly
dismiss it, move on.
And so the goal that you've set
out, you had really good
intentions, but it didn't
get accomplished.
One thing is that we are
working on help best
practices, or patterns
for that.
And you know that in the action
overflow, help is
something that we recommend be
put there, at the bottom.
And as that becomes more and
more common, I think users
will look for that, actively,
when they need help.
MICHAEL MOUSSA: That
makes sense.
We actually do have
it over there.
If you click on the overflow
menu, you have a
little help in there.
We just figured, first thing
they'll do, they'll probably
run into that issue that I was
saying, where they don't
properly know how to operate
the application.
And because of that, then we
decided alright, well let's
pop it, and then let's also
allow them the option to,
anytime they want, they can go
back through it, through the
overflow menu, and hit help.
But I do agree with you guys.
Although it did reduce, a little
bit, the amount of
support that we would get, or
support emails, rather, we've
also gotten a couple emails
about users saying, hey
listen, seems like it's a
little too many pages.
And we did have some instances,
I don't know if you
remember, where there's a little
check box in there we
have and it says don't
show again.
Check on it, hit continue, next
time they load the app,
the help screen won't show up.
A lot of people actually didn't
see the check box, even
though it's right there.
They would hit continue, and
then next time they would open
the app, the splash beam
would show up.
So there's definitely
some pros and cons.
JENS NAGLE: And that was one of
the other pieces of advice
that I wanted to give.
Do give people an option to bail
out on the first screen.
Don't force them to go through
eight pages, but say, OK, I
feel like I got this
handled, so I'm
going to skip the tutorial.
Especially when you have it
covered in the overflow menu
later on, so you can go
back and revisit it.
MICHAEL MOUSSA: Maybe we don't
show it on default, and they
have to access it through
the overflow menu.
Maybe that's a good way.
MARCO PAGLIA: And something that
I wanted to say, is that
you guys would be surprised.
We do so many user testing
around the out of the box
experience with an
Android device.
And you know we have those
screens that shows up once,
and they tell how to add
something for the home screen,
and things like that.
So even though you are excited,
you just got a new
device, you probably are
more likely to be
reading these things.
Still, people don't do it.
People just want to get right
into the experience.
MICHAEL MOUSSA: I don't
do it, either.
JENS NAGLE: I think
we have some
questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hey guys.
I actually just wanted to
share an experience.
I'm thinking back to when I was
a kid, and the first time
I came across an equalizer,
the bass and the treble
buttons on a stereo.
It's completely magical, where
all of a sudden, you bump the
bass and the whole
house shakes.
Everything's effected
immediately.
You didn't have to explain
anything to me, I just had to
turn the knob.
Later on in life, when I saw a
graphic equalizer, you have
colors, you have, like, six,
seven, eight colors and knobs
that you could turn up
and down immediately.
You don't have to tell me what
it does, all I have to do is
turn a couple down, and you
can hear it immediately.
And that's the great thing about
a graphic equalizer.
The way I see your app, I think
there's probably two
different types of users.
One is going to be your
audiophile, the person who
wants to get in there, and
really tweak, and make their
performance optimal.
Another person is just going to
be entertained purely with
playing with the manipulation
of sound.
I think, maybe, that's
something
you guys can consider.
AUDIENCE: It seems to me, if
users are asking for a music
player, you should just
put a basic music
player in there by default.
ALEX ROCHA: That makes sense.
AUDIENCE: You're going to have
beginners and intermediate
audiophiles, and then
audiophiles
will find their tools.
And then, this way,
there is no--
by default, they use
your music player.
And you've done so much work,
already, on this.
I'm sure it wouldn't be
trouble to, basic--
MICHAEL MOUSSA: Stay tuned.
Check out our website.
Something's coming.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
First of all, congratulations
for the app.
I find it super useful, so
I'll get it, definitely.
I kind of agree with the
blue shirt girl.
RACHEL GARB: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: These kind of
interruptions for the user are
kind of annoying, especially
the first
time you get the app.
So on Toast, of course,
are really ugly.
One solution that we are using
for our app, for Wunderlist--
you can download it, all
of us, all of you.
It's a really smart solution.
What we do is, we kind of make
hints live when you open the
app for the first time.
So we show the main screen,
and we kind of add some
graphics around, in the corners,
where more difficult
places for users are.
So it's kind of, you're
not blocking the user.
You have all the functionality
there.
And you show them, you can plan
the user a tick box, just
not to show them again.
ALEX ROCHA: I think I've seen
what you're saying.
And there's a couple instances
where developers will come up
with an overlay pop-up
that shows up.
And then they'll say, all right,
click here, and then
this will do this and that.
All they gotta do is click
outside, anywhere on the
screen, and then the
pop-up dismisses.
So that might be a
better option.
AUDIENCE: And you're
not, like, killing.
You're not interrupting.
MARCO PAGLIA: So I think we're
out of time, but let's talk a
little bit more after
the show.
[GONG SOUNDS]
MARCO PAGLIA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO PAGLIA: So we have
two more apps to go.
The next one is going
to be Latify.
And I welcome on stage,
Davy De Waele.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVY DE WAELE: Hello, welcome.
I'm Davy.
Marco was kind enough to give
me his phone, because mine
obviously has a wi-fi cell
radio problem here.
So the application, Latify, is
basically a way to control how
your location and location
history is
processed by your phone.
It's basically a Google Latitude
client that allows
you to have fine-grained
location updates being managed
from the application.
It also allows you to upload
your location to other Google
services like Fusion Tables,
stuff like that.
It allows you to share your
location, location history.
So everything related
to location and
location history, basically.
[GONG SOUNDS]
RACHEL GARB: So Davy, I am blown
away by the amount of
features you have in the app.
I mean, this thing, as you said
in the description in the
Google Play store, this
is a feature-rich app.
And sometimes, with feature rich
apps, we have challenges
in terms of how to promote all
that it can do without
overwhelming the user.
So I guess the question I have
for you is, of all the things
that this can do, what is
the most important.
DAVY DE WAELE: Yeah, so like I
said, it's basically kind of a
geeky, techie application.
So it's kind of a derived from
a Google Latitude API sample
that I did, and it kind of
grew to this feature-rich
application.
So I think the important aspect
of this application is
that it allows you to really
fine grain the way that your
location updates are pushed to
Google Latitude, and Fusion
Tables, and stuff like that.
So you can really define
the interval.
Do you want to use GPS, Wi-Fi?
What do you want to do if you
don't have an internet
connection?
Should it sync that afterwards,
should it sync it
automatically, stuff
like that.
So it's the way that
your location is
pushed to Google, basically.
RACHEL GARB: OK.
With that, I thought we could
take a look, together, at your
action bar that you have now.
It's a definite improvement from
the previous version, I
think, in terms of
iconography.
You're using some
standard ones.
MARCO PAGLIA: Actually, for
clarity, what you see here is
the current application
available on market to the
left, and this one is the
application that he's
currently building.
RACHEL GARB: Yeah so right away,
I can tell, ahh, I can
share, I can refresh.
There are some familiar
things here.
And then there are few I wasn't
so sure about, but they
fit in visually.
I think Peter can speak to it.
There are two things that I
wanted to talk about with the
action bar.
One is, is there a way
that we could have
fewer, do you think?
In terms of importance, are all
these equally important,
are there things that--
DAVY DE WAELE: You mean the
action items on the bottom?
RACHEL GARB: Yeah that's
right, those icons.
DAVY DE WAELE: Yeah--
MARCO PAGLIA: They're
all important!
DAVY DE WAELE: It's always
difficult to, kind of, remove
stuff, but I'm sure that--
for me, they're kind of
equally important.
RACHEL GARB: Well, I'll
give a suggestion.
One thing is that users are
accustomed, and I think
they'll be more accustomed, in
the future, to going to the
overflow menu for help.
And the one thing that I think
you don't want to do--
when you put help front and
center like that, it
kind of sends a--
what do you call it-- subliminal
message, this thing
is difficult to use.
So that's one you
could easily--
and then you're down to
five, yeah, four.
PETER ANG: Yeah, and touching
on Rachel's point, a lot of
times in visual design, there's
just a lot of stuff.
And you really want to direct
a user's view and focus
towards one place, which
would be the map
and your main actions.
And then you could draw those
icons even flatter and
flatter, but you can draw them
flatter than how they are
right now, right.
And so a lot of the time, visual
design is about picking
and choosing the important
things, and removing and
sticking other things, and
stashing them away.
RACHEL GARB: While you're up
here, Peter, I did want to ask
you about a particular icon.
So the pin, right?
So there's a pin icon here,
there's a pin in the middle of
the map, and there's also a pin
in the Latify launcher.
PETER ANG: So I think GigBeat
did a really good job with how
they expressed their brand,
was, they had a
subtle cue of pink.
And they had the same shape,
that kind of permeated through
the whole app, right.
And then, you could
also do the same.
Like, the pin is the
hero in this app.
And then if you really created,
whether it be a pin,
or that Google shape, place
thing, and then you have that
consistent everywhere, it's
really recognizable.
And you could really showcase
that as the hero of your
application.
DAVY DE WAELE: I'll check with
the designer that I'm probably
going to have to hire.
RACHEL GARB: And speaking of
pin, can you describe for us
what this does?
This particular--
DAVY DE WAELE: Yeah, so
basically what this pin does,
is that, as it says in the
horrible Toast, it allows you
to set your location manually,
without using
the Wi-Fi or GPS.
So it basically allows you to
tap around the map and allows
you to set a location
manually.
RACHEL GARB: So what happens,
let's say that I didn't have
that manual on, and I were to
touch somewhere on the map.
What would it do?
DAVY DE WAELE: Then it
would just be the
standard map behavior.
RACHEL GARB: Panel, what do you
think about trying to make
the manual setting of location
more direct manipulation,
where you don't have
to touch something.
DAVY DE WAELE: Like a long
press, or something?
Or--
RACHEL GARB: I'm not sure what
the right answer is, but just,
when I think of, if this is
something that people are
going to do a lot, just
be able to touch.
And then maybe blow up.
MARCO PAGLIA: Yeah, it
really feels like--
I see all the actions here
in the action bar
at the bottom, right.
And then, when I tap on the
screen, nothing happens.
And it really feels like you
should be able to take some of
these primary actions and put
them on the pin itself.
It kind of surprises that if I
tap on the pain, I don't get
an interaction.
So that's, I think, the message
we want to build.
Let's put the actions
where they matter.
Let's just don't be lazy and be
like, OK, there's an action
bar for that.
We'll put everything in there.
Let's try to think about where
they can be in the view.
Because the more we embed them,
the more we map them
where they matter, the more
people will find them.
RACHEL GARB: OK.
Question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: About the icons
on the bottom--
I'm a developer, too, and I
understand all the features
that we implement are super
important to us.
But we always roll analytics in,
and see what our users are
actually using.
And we can use that data to rank
the different features
that we have there and maybe not
include them all, back to
your point.
So sort them by priority, and
maybe get rid of some of the
ones that aren't used
terribly often.
DAVY DE WAELE: That's definitely
a good point, yeah.
JEREMY LYON: One thing is, be
careful about when you use
analytics in that way, though.
Of course, your design is going
to bias people towards
selecting certain buttons.
So there is definitely room for
analytics, but I think it
also requires a lot of thinking
ahead and trying it
out yourself.
RACHEL GARB: Switching topics,
can we go to the screen where
you have the profiles?
I don't think you were
able to describe it.
Well actually, why don't
we just stay on here.
Let's stay here.
While we're here right now,
another question.
This goes back to iconography.
I've noticed that when--
each of these has an icon, and
when you navigate there, your
app icon changes.
And I wondered about that,
because I'm accustomed to
seeing the app icon persistent
through an app.
And when I first saw the globes,
I thought, oh, that's
the browser.
What are your thoughts about not
having icons at all, for
the other choices there?
DAVY DE WAELE: I think the
fact that there are now
different icons shown,
is because each
activity has its own icon.
And the action bar was kind of
using the spinner control,
which kind of loads up all the
activities here, and this
behavior kind of came
out of the box.
But it can be made differently,
of course.
RACHEL GARB: Yeah, I wonder if
it would take away all that
much if there were
no icons at all.
DAVY DE WAELE: Also in this,
over in this spinner control.
I kind of got this from the
Google Maps application, which
kind of did it in that way.
RACHEL GARB: Ahh, I see.
DAVY DE WAELE: It's exactly
the same pattern.
RACHEL GARB: OK.
Well, that's something that we
might question on the maps
product, too.
DAVY DE WAELE: You have the
places Also different icons.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah, the older
version of the G+ app
was similarly guilty of that.
DAVY DE WAELE: I'm following
your pattern, but you're not
playing with that.
RICHARD FULCHER: Bless
your heart.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVY DE WAELE: But I was
thinking about placing this
with the kind of slide-in
thing from Google+ now?
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah, so I
think that pattern would be a
really good match for
this context, right?
Because they tend to be
exclusive modes that you would
be in within the application.
And just kind of bringing in
that panel instead of the
drop-down, especially if you
want to cosmetically add the
icons to add differentiation
between the different ones.
You wouldn't necessarily even
have to carry those individual
icons forward from that point,
but to just kind of make
identification easier is a
reasonable way to go, I think.
DAVY DE WAELE: It also allows
you to put more stuff in it,
like notification stuff.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah, I mean,
for this app I could imagine
you could have a packet which
was explaining the current
state of what you were
broadcasting.
Like in addition to, here is the
stuff I can navigate to,
here's the current state of what
I'm transmitting as far
as my location goes
to latitude.
MARCO PAGLIA: There's something
here, though, I
think should be important to
reference which is preferences
and health are not
really much--
normally you use this pattern
when you have different
applications within
an application.
It's a lot of features.
But the preference is in
Help for the settings.
They normally go under
an overflow.
This is how people are
trained to find it.
And especially because if they
go under an overflow, they can
find it in different screens,
and not just in the main
screen where you have it.
There's just a little detail.
RACHEL GARB: Do we have time for
one more question, or were
you about to gong?
RICHARD FULCHER: No, no, no.
Go ahead.
One more.
RACHEL GARB: OK.
Why don't we take one more
question from the audience?
AUDIENCE: So looking at the
pin, when you press it,
there's no real sort of context
change for the user.
I was wondering whether you
should do something similar to
in the list screens, where the
header then sort of changes,
and it goes a sort of darker
blue in ICS, whether something
like that would kind of help
the user know what mode
they're in.
DAVY DE WAELE: You mean like if
you press on a pin and you
change like the action bar?
AUDIENCE: Well if you press
in the pin on the
action bar now, yeah.
If there's no indication
that you're--?
DAVY DE WAELE: Yeah.
That can also be, yeah.
RACHEL GARB: Yeah, in different
icon states.
Do we have time for one more
topic within Latify?
OK.
Profiles page.
When I saw this, what jumped out
to me immediately, and I
also work on it a lot,
is settings and
the settings pattern.
These look like settings to
me, although you've called
them profiles.
Do you think a lot of people
will use them often and change
them often, or will they
set it and forget it?
They will?
DAVY DE WAELE: Yeah, this is
kind of the part which is
primarily used, because people
like put it in driving mode
because they want to update
their location every 30
seconds and get a really nice
trail of their trip.
RACHEL GARB: And then
when they're done,
they turn it off.
DAVY DE WAELE: When they're
at home, they put it in 10
minutes, 30 minutes, to see that
OK, I was at home for 8
hours, or I was at work
for 10 hours.
RACHEL GARB: But will they
come here a lot to change
these choices, or will they--
DAVY DE WAELE: Usually
it's done like once.
They basically set it up, and
then there's either a widget
to quickly change profile, or
there is integration with
applications like Task or
Lookout to automatically
switch them based on
certain conditions.
RACHEL GARB: So I would suggest
that if it's true that
these are not changed a lot,
these preferences, that you
merge them with settings, that
you merge them with your
preferences and have
a setting section
in your action overflow.
Because that's reserved for
things that aren't used a lot,
and that will also help in terms
of reducing the number
of choices on your
main screen.
Now, in terms of design of the
profiles, definitely take a
look at the settings pattern
in the design guide.
We've got patterns that exist
for all of these so that you
don't have to use big buttons.
In terms of these question
marks, it's interesting that
help's come up a few times
now in the session,
which I think is great.
So you have help choices for
every single setting, and
there are--
let's see, there's
seven of them.
And they're big and they're
blue, and I'm wondering, what
if they weren't there?
Could there be another way that
you could provide help?
DAVY DE WAELE: She's tough!
RICHARD FULCHER: The girl
in blue is subtle.
DAVY DE WAELE: I tried to put
all this text into this
screen, but it's not possible.
I don't know.
RACHEL GARB: Again, like the
point I made earlier, when you
have a question mark that's
given a lot of prominence, it
says to somebody, it kind
of sends that subliminal
message-- this is scary.
And now you have
seven of them.
DAVY DE WAELE: It is kind of
scary, because there are a lot
of settings.
And I think it's specific to
this type of application,
because I really want to
give the user this
fine-grained control.
And with that fine-grained
control comes a little bit of
additional information that
they might need, I think.
RACHEL GARB: So my suggestion
would be, explore how these
labels could be as informative
as possible without getting
very wordy.
I know that can be
tough to do.
And maybe your dialogues,
as well.
RICHARD FULCHER: And you don't
have to feel constrained,
necessarily, to equal
height list items.
You could have a three- or
four-line block of text under
each item if it would really be
helpful to explain in this
context, and just take
the touch away.
So to provide the same
content, but just
make it more immediate.
RACHEL GARB: Or if you think
that all of this explanation
might be useful to see all
together at once, like these
choices relate to another,
consider having one help
choice for the entire screen in
the action or [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
One more question and then--
MARCO PAGLIA: One more question,
then we get to--
AUDIENCE: Another way that we
could do the Help on that is
simply provide, on the label,
a link to the same Help, so
that if you tapped on Location
Polling Interval, on that
text, it would bring up
that information.
And that way you could remove a
control entirely, and you've
still got affordance for
the full information.
And then, if you also added a
subtext in there, you could
provide a little bit of help,
and then if somebody touched
it you could provide
the whole help.
MARCO PAGLIA: Yeah,
I was thinking
about something similar.
It's a very good insight.
And I think it talks about,
again, this message we're
trying to deliver, which is, try
to have the actions where
they matter, rather
than creating
them outside the view.
And with that, thank you
very much, Davy.
RACHEL GARB: Yeah,
thanks, Davy.
MARCO PAGLIA: So this is the
last application, and I invite
you all to stay.
Because it's going to
be a lot of fun.
As soon as we got this
application as a volunteer, we
were like, oh, yeah, we
need to do it, because
it's so much fun.
And we played with it.
So I'm really happy to have
Oren onstage with us
presenting Face Blender.
OREN BENGIGI: OK.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Oren Bengigi.
I've been developing for
about two years ago.
My previous experience was
doing image processing.
And Face Blender is an app that
was set to solve a very
important problem of taking
two different faces and
blending them into one face.
So if you want to see how you
and your girlfriend's children
will look like, you
can use this app.
This is the UI.
You can go to the Blend Face
UI, and from here, you can
open up the camera.
Maybe we do a live demo.
Anyone want to--
OK.
Just a second.
So we got one face.
I'll take another one.
OK.
Can you see that?
So you just press a button.
You don't have to do anything.
And this is the result.
[APPLAUSE]
OREN BENGIGI: And you have
tabs, you can see
the original faces.
And sometimes the face
detections go
wrong, so you can--
[GONG SOUNDS]
OREN BENGIGI: Out of time.
JEREMY LYON: So, when Marco
asked me to work on Face
Blender, I thought I pretty much
won the lottery out of
all of the people who were here,
because everybody else
had to work.
I got to make goofy pictures.
It's awesome.
So if you can go to
the slides, Marco.
So yeah.
I pretty much walked around
annoying all of my coworkers
by forcing them to look into
the camera and take
pictures with me.
So this is me and my wife, and
thankfully our children don't
actually look like this.
So we're safe there.
And this is me and our co-worker
Jeff, who has gone.
Go on to the next one, please.
Me and Richard Nho.
He's somewhere around here.
You may have seen him
earlier today.
Go to the next one.
Now this one is actually
me and Sergey, I think.
No, this is me and Rachel,
actually, taken earlier today.
One more?
Here's me and Sergey, with the
glasses on and everything.
I'm hoping this will
get me promoted.
I don't know if I'm going to
have that luck or not.
So obviously this app
is all about fun.
And if you take a look at the
screen that we're looking at
right now, there's some very
interesting subtle cues that
tell you that this app
is all about fun.
First of all, you've got this
cool, bright, blend
background.
You've got that kind of
hand-lettered font, making it
feel like, hey, come play.
We're not going to do anything
important here.
We're going to have fun.
And you've got the cool
little icon going
in the corner there.
So everything about the style
of this screen, I think,
really says, let's have fun.
But then you look
at the content.
And I don't know about you guys,
but file manipulation is
pretty low on my list
of fun things to do.
I look at this screen--
I look at Load and Delete and
About, and I can understand
how those are important actions,
things that people
might want to be able to do,
but they aren't fun.
They take a little bit
away from where I
really want to go.
Where I really want to go with
this app is to that first
button there, that
Blend Faces.
I want to just jump
right in and
start taking some pictures.
So we'll talk in a second about
maybe some ways we could
do that, but let's go on
to the next screen.
So you hit that Blend
Faces button, and
this is what you see.
Again, we've got a nice
consistent feel,
a consistent style.
It still keeps that sort
of playful feel to it.
But there's a lot of
things that you
can do on this screen.
If I look at it, there's--
just for the one key action that
I'm most interested in,
which is getting a picture
loaded up to start the
blending process, I've
got six buttons.
I've got the big, nice
affordance of the picture
frame, which is where my finger
just is magnetically
attracted to touch.
And then I have the Camera
button, and I
have a Facebook button.
These are all different ways
of loading up a picture.
And I have each one of those
for both pictures.
I've got six different buttons
that I have to look at when
I'm looking at this screen.
Which can be a little
intimidating, perhaps.
And also, I just have to think a
lot harder than I want to to
work with a fun application.
So I think I think one of the
things that you should think
about doing with this
application is really trying
to get right into taking
that first picture.
Jumping right into the big
picture frame, before you show
any of your file manipulation
stuff.
Jump right into here.
Show a big picture, maybe show
a button that helps you to
understand a secondary action.
I mean, one of the themes, I
think, that at least we've
been saying for most of the apps
that we've looked at so
far today is that
less is more--
that the more you can pull out
of your UI, the more you can
make decisions about what's the
most important aspect, the
better off I think you're
going to be.
So I would look at those six
actions that you've got there.
Maybe eliminate them down to
three by starting with just
one picture, and moving
the user along
to the second picture.
OREN BENGIGI: Oh,
like a result?
You go from screen to screen?
JEREMY LYON: Yeah.
Yeah, that's one option.
You want to draw a
little bit, Rich?
Rich is going to save you all
from seeing my completely
illegible scribbling.
And another option can think
about here is, are all three
of those ways of getting an
image equally important?
You probably have a better
idea how users use this
application.
But I would argue that using the
camera to take a picture,
that's what I want
to do probably
about 80% of the time.
And then picking something from
the gallery, that's kind
of fun too, because that's
how I got to get
Sergey's picture in there.
And Facebook, I can see how that
could be useful, though
of course I'm a Google+ user,
so I don't know what this
Facebook thing is.
But--
RICHARD FULCHER: So much
smarter than me.
JEREMY LYON: Yeah.
Did we switch over?
Yes.
It's almost as though you
read my mind, Rich.
Yeah, this is one option
that we could do.
What Rich is drawing here is,
we've got a big image in the
center you could use
for your camera.
Tap on that big image in the
center and switch to the
camera view that
you had before.
And you have a smaller image
so you can see the other
options that you might
have available.
Or sorry, what the other picture
is, if you've already
taken a picture, or is
not, or will soon be
when you get there.
And then you could have two
different actions for the
Facebook and for the camera.
I might even go further and
say, pick your secondary
action, link it up to that big
picture, and put your tertiary
action in the overflow
menu somewhere.
Which you don't currently have,
but we'll get there.
What do you think?
I mean, I don't know if anybody
has other opinions
about this.
OREN BENGIGI: What about
the swap button to
swap between the faces?
RICHARD FULCHER: I think
you can just
make it a direct touch.
So it's like, this is the
face I'm editing now.
It's larger, so it has
prominence, so I'm going to
shoot picture, pick from
gallery, or maybe I can just
kind of tap directly.
If I tap, you can just kind of
toggle the position of those.
There's kind of the one active
one, and maybe after I take a
picture, we automatically
toggle it.
So it's like, you could even
say Face A, Face 1, take a
picture, they switch
positions.
The animation cues
you a little bit
to the state change.
Maybe it rotates to be Face 2.
And then the Blend button is
your nice big target down at
the bottom.
I mean, you could also
do this as--
I kind of like the swap here,
because then you don't have to
have different screens.
But you could imagine, the user
could also go through a
progression of screens where
screen 1 is Face 1.
And then that glides
over to Face 2.
And then maybe they don't even
hit the Blend button.
They just swipe over to see
the blended version.
So something like
that could work.
OREN BENGIGI: Yes.
JEREMY LYON: So that's
screen notes.
Let's go onto the screen that
you see once you actually have
finished entering in both.
So what you're looking
at here is--
over there, I should
say-- is--
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY LYON: You wouldn't
see all three of
these at the same time.
These are three different taps
displayed in this view.
And the thing I think is most
interesting to note about
this, especially after we've
looked at the last two
screens, is that in the last
two screens, we've got this
nice, colorful background, we've
got the hand-lettering--
boom.
Here we're into something that
feels very frameworky.
We've got this gray action bar,
we've got the blue tabs,
we've got the white
background.
It almost feels like I'm in a
different app, and it loses a
lot of the fun, the
playfulness of
the previous screens.
And you might think, working
on Android design, I might
cheer for the action bar and
the standard framework
elements here, but I think,
actually, this is a case where
sticking with the integrity of
your application, the visual
integrity of your application,
would be the way to go, to
have that nice, seamless
throw.
So I'm a little bit curious
about why you chose to go this
direction with the screen.
OREN BENGIGI: Well, the idea was
to have the ability to see
all the different
faces you took,
including the blended one.
And sometimes face detection
goes wrong, so you can go and
edit blend.
And you can just manually adjust
the detected face, and
do it to the other
face, like this.
And once you hit Apply, it
reblends the faces, and you
get a better result.
Or worse, I don't know.
RICHARD FULCHER: I think I've
become a V For Vendetta mask.
A Ugnaught.
JEREMY LYON: Well, there might
be some ways to get those same
kinds of actions available to
you, even using your own
custom background.
But one of the things you can
do with action bar-- action
bar doesn't need to use the
framework gray background.
You can actually use a
transparent background.
So you can keep your own
background image there, the
one that you've had earlier,
and draw that there.
Likewise, you can change the
font for your app title there.
You could use the same font that
you were using earlier so
you keep that consistency.
And I might look at something
instead of tabs, which are
effective ways of jumping
between these three screens.
But going back to what Rich was
drawing, you might think
about doing this sort of more
direct manipulation.
I don't know if part of what you
were trying to do here was
make this image as big as
possible in this view, but you
might be able to sacrifice a
little bit of space around the
edges to kind of hint at the A
and the B on either side, or
perhaps it's a linear
progression--
I don't know what the right
approach is here--
where you can directly
manipulate, just swapping
between the two starting
pictures
and the blended picture.
And if you chose to use the
action bar throughout your
application, even in the earlier
screens that we saw,
and maintain that playfulness
with the transparency and the
font changes on the title, you
could put in there your
overflow menu.
And that gives you a place to
put things like Load and
Delete and the actions that
perhaps you don't want to give
the same kind of prominence to
when you're really trying to
get someone just to have fun and
start taking pictures, but
you need to have available
to the user there.
OREN BENGIGI: Yeah, I agree.
The interface here is too
serious, I think, for--
JEREMY LYON: This screen, yes.
MARCO PAGLIA: Do you want to
show the Skype application?
JEREMY LYON: Sure.
What?
MARCO PAGLIA: The Skype
application as an example.
JEREMY LYON: Sure.
MARCO PAGLIA: I think this is
what Jeremy is talking about.
There are applications
already that have a
transparent action bar.
So really, you can keep your
application feeling full
screen, and you still have that
affordance that's really
important to have consistent,
which is the overflow menu.
So there are a lot of ways to
play with your application,
not to make it feel like, oh,
this is an action bar, and
this is this element
from the framework.
You can play with it and make
it feel like a full screen
experience, and this is
a perfect example.
JEREMY LYON: Were there
any questions or
comments from the audience?
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to think
that, potentially, the
first page in the app, he could
completely get rid of
it, and just bring up the second
page, have the action
bar with the Load, Delete,
and About, and
basically go right there.
That's my first idea.
JEREMY LYON: I think that's
a great idea.
That's also what I
was suggesting.
AUDIENCE: So a comment about
the image selection screen.
I think your suggestion is a
great improvement, but I'm
still not 100% sold on it.
I was wondering if maybe--
you made a comment about your
eyes drawn towards the images
and you just want
to touch them.
Maybe there's just two buttons
with the placeholder images.
When you touch one, there's a
secondary level of choice.
And I don't know if--
I'm guilty of not having
reviewed the new Android
design guidelines, so is there
any affordance that would be
appropriate to accomplish
that?
JEREMY LYON: I'm not sure
there's anything that would be
a common secondary
action level.
You certainly could tap into
it and have a change in the
action bar.
Action bar supports that sort
of behavior, so your action
bar could add icons
if you want to.
I had thought about that, too,
when I was looking at this
app, and I chose not to
recommend that primarily
because I think that, in order
to make that work well, you
kind of need to be a little
bit interruptive.
I tap into this big, beautiful
picture frame, and then I get
asked how I want to get
the picture in there.
And I think you could probably
make a good primary choice and
allow the other ones to kind of
fade into the background,
so that if someone's looking
for an alternate choice,
they'll see it, but if they're
not, they don't have to kind
of mentally parse it.
That's my theory.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah,
I mean, one other--
we'll do more questions, but
one other thing to keep in
mind is, there are lots of
capabilities in Android that
might not seem like natural
matches for an app like this,
but really could be great.
And I think Beam, or the NFC,
could be one of them.
Imagine you've got two
users that each
have this app installed.
They just take their own
pictures and then touch to
blend, effectively, would
be what you'd be
doing at that point.
Because then both users kind
of get that surprise at the
same time, and it just
kind of shortens it.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Well, I had actually
two suggestions.
So the first was, this is fun.
People have had it
for a while.
They might have accumulated
some images
that they've saved.
So rather than come up directly
into Face Blender,
come up with some thumbnails
in a gallery, and have the
Face Blender button right there,
significant, prominent.
And be able to show some of
your most recent or pick
favorites as your
start screen.
So instead of an empty screen
that you need to fill with
faces to blend, you've got some
funny ones that you've
already made.
The second suggestion
was the tabs.
Tabs are kind of--
I love tabs, really, I do, and
three tabs are what I love.
I have a tab widget app.
It doesn't work that
well, though.
You could put like an A on the
left and a B on the right, and
have the blended face in the
middle-- swipe to see face B,
swipe to see face A. And maybe
have some options to shrink
them and have all
three of them.
Especially in a tablet view,
you could have all three.
But my suggestion would be to
put the blended face in the
middle, and not on the end.
That's what occurred to me.
JEREMY LYON: To your first
comment, Oren actually has
developed-- there is a sort of
a gallery viewing widget.
I just didn't show it in this
UI, because I thought these
things were the most
important.
MARCO PAGLIA: OK.
Last question.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask
about the Blend button.
Because the natural place for
me to put it would be the
action bar--
like, one of the actions in the
action bar just blends.
And then I, myself, found a
problem in one of my apps that
people don't like it there,
so I put two buttons.
And this an alternative.
So I wanted to know what are
your thoughts on this?
What are your thoughts on two
buttons or the button on the
action bar, for the
main action in
the form, like Blend.
JEREMY LYON: I would usually
put your main
action in the form.
If you have something where
there's stuff going on in the
main part of the screen, like
we have in Face Blender, and
then an action that acts on all
that stuff that you just
did, it makes a lot of sense
to embed that in the view
instead of putting it up
in the action bar.
If you have--
I'm thinking of the People
application, for example--
this is something where you're
doing a lot of different
things when you're editing
a contact.
We have the Done button up in
the action bar, that because
it applies to the entirety of
the screen, and not only just
the screen that you're viewing
right now, but pieces that you
may have been looking at,
scrolled up, scrolled down.
It's less of an immediate
response to the content that's
immediately above it.
Instead it's more of a, at this
time, I am now finished.
So it kind of depends on
how you're using it.
But what I'm getting a little
bit from your description is,
I would probably put
that primary action
in the content itself.
MARCO PAGLIA: This
is the time.
[GONG SOUNDS]
JEREMY LYON: Wait, wait, wait!
I've got one more picture.
Go to the next one?
Just to end with a little--
This is me and Brad Pitt.
I was hoping he would improve
me, but I don't think it
improved either of us,
unfortunately.
Thanks a lot.
OREN BENGIGI: Thank you.
MARCO PAGLIA: So thank
you very much.
Most of you have been here for
two hours, so pretty much
thank you for myself, from our
guests, and from our team.